Hallo Hallo, sag mal, haben wir den Vogel zweimal?
Ist der Vogel zweimal da?
Fuck, warum?
Moment, ich muss mal gucken, warum ist der Vogel zweimal da?
Deswegen, ha?
Ah, jetzt ist der Vogel nur einmal da, sehr nice.
So, haben wir Qualitätsoptionen.
Allerwichtigste Frage des Tages, Qualitätsoptionen.
Ach so, wie ist die Lautstärke eigentlich?
Das verstellt sich ja dank Windows jedes Mal.
Ah, das geht so, glaub ich.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, bis Twitch das gecheckt hat, dass ich online bin.
So, ähm, also, heute programmieren wir aber nix.
Heute spielen wir mal so testweise, ich meine, ich spiele das immer schon eben bei, aber
noch nie on stream, weil ich nicht weiß, ob es jemand interessiert, geschweigert, wie
gut es sich des eignet zum streamen.
Heute spielen wir mal ein uralt MMO, das ist rausgekommen seit, vor 20 Jahren ungefähr.
Meiner Meinung nach immer noch das beste MMO, was, äh, je gemacht wurde.
Ja, doch, Funs.
Wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach das beste MMO, was je gemacht wurde.
Ich bin ja mittlerweile auch schon relativ weit, ähm, ich muss mich jetzt bloß mal kurz
einstellen, dass das Ingame auch ordentlich funktioniert.
Und ich sag euch, äh, für heutige Verhältnisse ist die Grafik wirklich, ähm, gewöhnungsbedürftig,
aber lasst euch davon mal nicht abstrecken.
Und wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie gut es zum zugucken ist.
Müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Ich mach jetzt erstmal Desktop Capture aus, und äh, dann gucken wir mal, ob es überhaupt
funktioniert, mit dass es das Game Captured.
Was, es, es, es, Captured das?
Ey, das Captured.
Jetzt kommt super hässlicher Charakterausfallscreen von 1998 oder so.
Nee, ich glaube rausgekommen ist das 2002 oder so.
Oh, falscher Char.
Der steht ja noch am Arsch der Welt rum.
Und ich hab auch noch die uralt grafik eingestellt leute ich habe auch noch die uralt grafik eingestellt ich habe jetzt noch die alten models das sieht wirklich grausam aus
Oh, wie sie laut, wie sie laut
Wie sie laut
Aber man braucht in dem spiel man braucht in dem game ein bisschen bisschen audiofeedback
Also ich darf es nicht zu leise machen ich muss es noch hören
Er ist jetzt zu leise
Immer noch zu leise
Ah jetzt geht es halbwegs
So wir wippen uns jetzt erstmal kurz
Wir wippen uns jetzt erstmal kurz
Und ich werde ein paar takt zum game sagen
Wobei warum sollten wir uns wippen wir können auch mal ein paar gegner killen
Guck mal da ist einer
Aber das ist ein grauer
Das ist ein grauer also das ist ein spieler
Da ist er gerade halt am level
Da muss ich jetzt gemein sein und den bashen
Aber das ist ein grauer und graue bringen
Keine punkte
Deswegen bringt das nichts
Ja das ist das game ist
Sehr verwirrend für leute das nicht kennen
Oh das ist doch noch ein bisschen laut
Deswegen weiß ich
Gar nicht so recht wo ich
Eigentlich anfangen soll deswegen spielen wir
Einfach mal ein bisschen und zwar das ist
Dark Age of Camelot das ist ein MMO
Von 2002
Oder so
Und
Das war das beste pvp system
Was ich jemals in einem MMO gesehen habe
Es gibt drei reiche es gibt quasi
So ein mittelalterliches england als reich
Es gibt das grüne hier
Es gibt so quasi das
Keltisch angehauchte und es gibt midgard
Das ist quasi das wo die vikinger rumrennen
Und das
Game hat im prinzip keine großartige
Story also das kann man nicht
Das ist eine levelgruppe allerdings auch nur
Graue da machen wir jetzt mal nichts
Also es lohnt sich eigentlich nur gelbe
Gegner zu killen und im grenzgebiet
Hier wo wir sind gibt es extra xp deswegen
Sind auch die ganzen grauen hier am leveln aber die killen wir nicht
Ja und das
Game hat im vergleich zu anderen MMOs nicht wirklich
Viele nicht viel story außer
Das könig atos gestorben ist und die drei reiche
Im krieg sind und sich bashen
Gegenseitig
Jedes reich hat drei verschiedene grenzgebiete
Aber wir sind hier gerade in
Berner also da holen wir
Reiche der Kelten oder was will ich sagen
Die hippies halt
Alles grau beim leveln da
Machen wir nichts und
In den grenzgebieten gibt es
Punkte für gegner killen
Es gibt besonders viel xp also im prinzip
Gräbst jeder irgendwie in den
Grenzgebieten rum
Ja RIP könig atos
Oh Moment Moment muss man nochmal aus
Geht überhaupt
Geht überhaupt das meme board ich stehe übrigens
Direkt vor der gegnerischen grenzfestung
Ich muss mal ein Stückchen mich hier verpissen
Easy
Ja beste
Ähm
Ja und ich versuche das
Mal ein bisschen zu erklären dass man überhaupt
Checkt um was es
Um was es geht also
Ähm
Tja wie fang ich da am besten an
Jedes reich hat
Und ich weit mich jetzt erstmal ich porte
Mal zurück in meine grenzfestung und dass man das
Ein bisschen sieht
Wobei vielleicht ist es gar nicht so clever
Na doch in 21 minuten
Ist pvp task in dem gebiet
Hier da kommen wir einfach wieder wenn es so weit ist
Ich weit mich jetzt mal das ist das was
Ich früher mit dem fabian gespielt habe genau
Da kenne ich den friseur her und den karsten
Also den master crabber wir können
Aber vielleicht noch irgendwo einen gegner finden den wir basten können kurz
Wie gesagt wir
Könnten die ganzen grauen hier vorne basten
Da ist eine gruppe auch alles graue
Das lohnt sich nicht
Dann versuche ich euch mal kurz
So ein bisschen die
Guckt mal der graue haut mich
Dafür muss er jetzt sterben
Aber graue können halt nichts
Habt ihr ja gesehen graue sind halt grau
Graue sind halt grau und das sagt
Oh da hinten ist ein gelber
Oh das ist highlevel
Okay wir versuchen den
Typ jetzt mal hier kurz
Ganz clever, ganz clever max
Hinterher
Den bleiben muss ich mal kurz konzentrieren
Vielleicht kriege ich den dude noch irgendwie
Down
Mal kurz abhauen
Oh ne
Okay der Typ hat nicht mehr
All zu viel Leben ich habe allerdings nichts mehr ready
Das wird jetzt ziemlich
Alter rennen
Rennen
Ja das wird nichts
Okay ich wollte mich eh weiten wunderbar
Da kann ich jetzt auch ein bisschen was zu erzählen
Okay ich habe natürlich
Alles sinnlos meine raas rausgehauen
Allerdings man hat in der regel auch
Nicht all zu viel chancen gegen ein gutes duo
Das war gerade ein bardo
Mit speed und ein tank
Da machst du nichts dagegen
Also ich porte jetzt mal zurück
In mein realm da kann ich ein bisschen was zu erzählen
Ja
Die Katze ist gefriest ja die habe ich gestern fotografiert
Auf dem Schrank
Das war eine Art fantasy
Noscope genau
Okay also nur so ganz kurz
Als intro hier sind leute auf meiner gilt
Ich stelle mich jetzt einfach mal der grenzfestung aufs dach
Und dann kann ich kurz was zu erzählen übrigens hier
Der beste Hut den ich auf hab
Oder machen wir es anders ich gehe mal kurz in charakter
Auswaldbildschirm nur das man so ungefähr
Eine ahnung hat
Wie das aufgebaut ist
Ich werde jetzt einfach nur 5 minuten was zu erzählen
Und danach
Ist wahrscheinlich auch pvp task und wir können
Wieder leute baschen
Also wie gesagt das spiel hat 3 reiche
Die sich quasi untereinander
Baschen im grenzgebiet um es mal so ganz kurz
Unter dem strich zusammenzufassen
Und hässlicher charakterbildschirm lasst euch
Davon mal nicht beeindrucken
Und das ist halt deswegen schön
Dynamisch es gibt 3 grenzgebiete von jedem
Reich und es kann jedes reich
In das andere reich porten und
Sich gegenseitig die körper einschlagen was halt sehr
Dynamisch macht weil du immer damit rechnen musst
Das wenn du dich gerade mit jemand anderes
pvpst
Das dann das andere realm dabei kommt
Also um euch immer kurz
Zu zeigen wie das aufgebaut ist
Das ist nicht so das ganz
Klassische wie man das auch
Von mmo's kennt also die charakter
Porten sind halt hässlich wie von 2002
Es ist
Prinzipiell in jedem reich relativ ähnlich aufgebaut
Man hat unterschiedliche rassen die dürfen
Unterschiedliche klassen werden man kann das
Übrigens auch alle klassen können man nicht so weiblich sein
Die sind prinzipiell aufgeteilt in
Wie bei jedem spiel allerdings
In dark ist das sehr weich aufgeteilt
Ja
Also die sind
Eigengeteilt in tanks supporter und
Caster und
Caster supporter tanks könnte man
Grob sagen allerdings
Es gibt dann auch schleicher die sich tarnen können
Es gibt hybrids
Es gibt light tanks die quasi nicht viel
Aushalten dafür viel damage machen
Im nahe kampf es gibt
Caster die im nahe kampf was auch ganz
Merkwürdig ist also
Im prinzip ist das sehr vielfältig
Und man sieht schon wieviel klassen jedes realm hat
Albion hat sogar noch ein bisschen mehr
Das heißt das
Ist relativ kompliziert deswegen
Sagt da gar nicht so viel und wenn man
Anfängt mit dem game checkt man nichts
Man versteht am Anfang nichts
Gar nichts
Was hab ich irgendwas überlehren
G-Sync
Ich hab keinen G-Sync monitor
G-Sync suck
Also nein G-Sync suck nicht
Aber G-Sync ist mir
Viel zu teuer fürs Geld
So jetzt reparieren wir erstmal unser
Tier zu wert und reparieren nochmal unsere Rüstung
So das ist
Nicht der offizielle Server das ist
Phönix das ist
Ein freeshard weil der offizielle
Live Server ist mittlerweile ziemlich
Tot der hat abends irgendwie
Keine Ahnung
80 Leute on und Phönix hat abends
Ungefähr 3000 Leute on
Und noch ein bisschen mehr am Wochenende der Woche ein bisschen weniger
Level 50 ist
Max level ja
Und
Man level im PVP
Im PVM sowie im PVP allerdings
Nachdem man level 50 ist
Und PVP
Macht kriegt man Punkte dafür und man sieht hier unten
Ganz klein ich bin aktuell
Rang 801
Also sprich das ist das was man nach level 50
Sammelt von insgesamt 11
Rängen die es gibt also das ist relativ
Hoch es geht noch höher als geht
Theoretisch bis 14 allerdings ist ab 11
Eigentlich erstmal Schluss dann braucht
Man sehr sehr lang und
Man kann sich von jedem Level
Ab hier unten kann man sich zusätzliche beim
Trainer zusätzliche Reicht
Fähigkeiten kaufen also sprich
Mehr Stärke mehr Aushalten
Oder halt auch irgendwelche aktiven
Fähigkeiten und die
Verbessern den Charakter
Unglaublich
Und was ich hier spiele
Esgald ist eines der besten Solo
Charaktere die es in dem Spiel gibt denn
Man hat eine zwei Hände zum draufhauen
Wie man hier sieht
Man hat halbwegs gute Styles wobei
Hammer eigentlich die bessere Waffe ist
Man hat mit Kettenrüstung
Relativ hält man viel
Aus
Und man hat ein bisschen
Range Damage
Man hat CC wo man die Gegner verlangsamen kann
Und jetzt kommt das beste
Was
In Sgald eigentlich zum besten
Mit dem besten Solo Charakter
Macht ist man sieht schon ich habe Speed
Also ne
Wenn ich Speed anmache und renne
Dann bin ich relativ schnell im Vergleich zu dem
Dude der hier rumspringt und
Halt nicht schnell ist
Also ich kann sie übrigens
Rumflitzen als Skalde was wichtig ist
Weil es gibt nichts schnelleres
Als eine Skalde mit
Speed plus Sprinten das heißt mich holt eigentlich
Nichts ein was
Sehr wichtig ist für Solo
So jetzt gucken wir mal was es
Für einen aktuellen RVR Task gibt
Also PVP nennt es hier
RVR weil es 3 Reiche sind
Das ist quasi Relen versus Relen
Und wir gucken mal was es
Für einen Task aktuell gibt also
Aktueller Task ist ich soll Midgard Defenden
Das ist hier in dem Reich wo ich gerade bin
Die Task läuft noch 14 Minuten
Ähm
Aktueller Task ist
Diese Festung
Hier zu beschützen allerdings nimmt die
Festung meistens eh keiner ein also wir können
Mal hinlaufen oder vielleicht können wir auch hin porten
Können wir hin porten?
Oh wir können hin porten kann ich euch gleich mal zeigen
Ja wir sind noch mehr Leute
Hingeportet
Ich mach mal so ganz kurz Tour durchs Grenzgebiet
Bevor wir jetzt
Bevor wir uns in die Schlacht stürzen
Das da oben ist eine Festung die können Gegner einnehmen
Unsere aktuelle Task ist die
Festung zu verteidigen das heißt
Wenn wir die Task schaffen kriegen wir extra Punkte
Und wenn die Gegner die Task
Schaffen kriegen wir extra Punkte
Dann gibt es noch weitere Tasks
Zum Beispiel dass man
Capture Points einnimmt
Im Prinzip sowas wie Domination
Also diese
Fahnen die ihr gerade gesehen habt kann man einnehmen
Kriegt man auch extra Punkte
Oder man kann so einen super special Boss
Der in jedem Grenzgebiet spawn killen
Da gibt es auch extrem viele Punkte
Und Ingame Währung und alles mögliche
Also es ist das haben sie hier auf dem
Privatsurfer relativ
Vielfältig gemacht
Achja warum die Katze unten links
Ich muss den Gilden chat
Ich muss das ausblenden
Das steht in den Regeln
Vom Server drin
Durch jedes Keep hat hier auch ein paar Wachen
Die das verteidigen aber ohne Spieler ist so ein Keep
Mit Ram relativ schnell weg
Das PvP ist halt auch dadurch relativ
Vielseitig dass es drei verschiedene Reiche gibt
Und
Dass halt auch verschiedene Sachen gibt
Es gibt offenes
So Openfield Kämpfe
Es gibt am Keep irgendwelche Kämpfe
Und das schlechteste Gebiet guck mal
Während ich weg war
Wurde die Flagge eingenommen
Von ein paar Gegnern die da hinten
Ganz clever gemacht
Max jetzt werden sie mich natürlich awnen
Hab ich sehr schlau gemacht
Dass ich in die Möpse gerannt bin
Ganz furchtbar clever
Das ist ein Alt wo er immer her kommt
Alter könnt ihr euch mal verpissen
Das ist keine Chance gegen fünf Gegner
Voll die Möpse reingerannt
Na gut
So jetzt können wir anfangen
Jetzt habe ich versucht euch so ungefähr zu erklären
Und wenn man nicht in die Möpse rein rennt
Kann man als Skalder auch gut abhauen vor den Gegnern
Ganz clever
Wir laufen jetzt mal
So
Das schlechteste Gebiet eigentlich
Für RVR ist Defend Midgard
Das sackt
Weil man selten porten kann
Ewig rennt
Und es dauert bis man Fights hat
So viel dazu
Die haben aktuell einen Event abends laufen
Das hier sind diese Special Event Zone
Da gibt es so eine extra PvP Zone
Da kann man auch gegen Leute in seinem eigenen Reich kämpfen
Und die haben auch so eine
PvP Zone da kann man auch gegen Leute in seinem eigenen Reich kämpfen
Meine Frage von euch
Hat das Spiel jemand gespielt?
Also kennt das überhaupt jemand?
Ich meine wie gesagt das ist alt
Weil
Sagen wir mal so Solo spielen
Ist das eine
So richtig glänzen tut das Spiel eigentlich
Wenn du in einer Achtergruppe spielst
Wieso man das heute noch spielt
Erstens weil es kostenlos ist
Das haben wir mal an einem Punkt vielleicht für einige
Und das nächste ist weil
Das finde ich immer noch das beste PvP überhaupt hat
So
Genau und jeder
Und jeder Kill bringt auch
So eine Ingame Währung in dem Fall
Wenn Midgard killt
Dann ist das
Schnee
Ein gelber Schnee
Schnee habe ich gerade gar keinen dabei
Den kann man bei einem NPC abgeben
Und dann kriegt man auch extra Punkte
Also immer ist auch erst mal wurscht
Wir suchen jetzt mal ein paar Gegner
Und hoffen dass wir ein paar einzelne finden
Das ist Midgard-Task ein bisschen schwierig
Hiptasks
Guck mal da sind welche
Da sind schon wieder 5 Gegner oder so
Ich bin einfach mit drauf
Da, bist du weg
Den stellen wir mal hin
Und machen mit unseren anderen Midis den einen
Dude hier fertig
Der ist ziemlich low
Excellent, zack
Next, GG Eats
Gut
Wir waren jetzt ja auch 4 Leute oder so
Jetzt wird natürlich auch ein bisschen emoted und T-backed
So wie das in jedem Game sein muss
Oh, mal kurz regnen
Heilsong an
Das wegen ist geil, da ist übrigens OP
Du hast alles was du brauchst für
Für Solo-Action
Du hast Speed, du hast
Einen Heilsong um dich zu heilen
Du hast Range Damage, du hast CC
Du hast im Prinzip alles
Und es ist relativ gefährlich sich in Dark
Irgendwo hinzusetzen
Weil überall irgendwelche Schleicher sein können
Die dich jetzt gleich tohitten
Ja
Ja, ich weiß die Grafik ist
Hard an Crysis dran
Aber
Dafür läuft es gut
Dafür läuft es mit 140 FPS
Da ist noch mehr
Was ist da drüben los
The fuck
Guck mal
Das sind jetzt Gegner aus dem einen Reich
Plus Gegner aus dem anderen Reich
Den müssen wir mal kurz hinstellen
Alter, kann der Typ mal mit draufhauen
Was geht mit Kartoffel ab
Toll
Alleine gegen drei kann ich jetzt auch nicht fighten
Ja, das ist ein Grauer, der macht auch nichts
So
Kurzen Heal zünden
Auf, Kollege
Speed, darf wieder angehen
Heilsong rein
Ja, und das ist das was ich schon gemeint habe
Das ist halt dadurch relativ dynamisch
Das ist jetzt
Das eine Reich gegen das andere Reich gekämpft
Plus
Jetzt wir halt noch schön rein geadded
Direkt
Und deswegen wird das eigentlich nie lang
War da was? Das war aber einer von uns
Glaube ich
Achja, übrigens in dem Spiel gibt es auch
Gibt es auch Umhänge
Aber ich finde Umhänge sehen doof aus
Deswegen mache ich Umhänge immer aus
Jetzt gehen wir mal
Hoch ans Keep und ranken mal kurz
Die Animationen sind
Richtig räudig, die sind richtig räudig
Das Game ist auch von 2002
Die Animation war aber damals schon ziemlich
Mies
Und
Das ist hier
Eine Festung, die ist ziemlich nah an unserem
Grenzkeep dran, also da wo man
Quasi dann ins Grenzgebiet reingeht
Da ist relativ wenig eigentlich an Gegner
Allerdings
Wenn das hier angegriffen wird
Man hat mal auch relativ schnell halt
Nachschub an Spielern
Und wenn man ordentlich viele
Caster reinkriegt, kann man das eigentlich nicht einnehmen
Da stellst du einfach deine Caster hier oben drauf
Und bam und alles ist tot
Ich hab solche, das ist ziemlich kacke
Da regt man nämlich kein Leben
Deswegen
Das ist scheiße, deswegen muss ich jetzt noch 20 Sekunden
warten bis solche weg ist
Jetzt weiß ich wenigstens wo
Guild Wars 2 die Welt fürs PvP hat
Es ist, es ist sehr stark
Also das Guild Wars 2 PvP
Ist sehr stark von Dark inspiriert
Man erkennt da wirklich viele Parallelen
So, solche weg
Ne, solche immer noch nicht weg
So und man kann sich ja noch seine Stats angucken
Was weiß ich, ich mach ungefähr 1000
RP pro Stunde
Hab 2 Deathblows, 1 tot
Genau
Ja und im Prinzip so als
Übersicht reicht das denke ich mal
Oh ich werd geheilt, krasser Scheiß
Können wir weiter
Wir müssen gucken, dass wir in
In 6 Minuten wechseln wir das Reich
Gehen wir ins Grüne
Und
Falls ihr euch fragt warum
Hier so ein Level 24 herumrennt
Ganz einfach, wenn du im Grenzgebiet levels
Kriegst du extra Punkte
Und ziemlich viele extra Punkte
Weil es hier halt auch viel gefährlicher ist
Da kann hier instant gegankt werden von irgendeinem Gegner
Das sind jetzt alles welche aus dem Reich
Da passiert nichts
Wo ist der NPC hin
Da kann ich jetzt ein bisschen Schnee
Abgeben wenn ich es finde
Weil ich für die Kills gekriegt habe
Dann gibt es wieder extra Punkte für
Guck mal ich krieg sogar Bass
Poggers alter
Ok gehen wir mal zuerst in Flagge
Und gucken ob wir da irgendwas einnehmen können
Und dann porten wir gleich mal ins andere Reich rein
Die Textur sind
Na super Server Restart
In 10 Minuten
Bestes Timing ey
Ok in 10 Minuten Server Restart
Allerdings ist es nicht schlimm
Der Server Restart geht immer schnell
Also das haben sie wirklich gut gemacht
Das dauert eineinhalb Minuten oder so
Dann ist das
Ja und warum ich das die ganze Zeit nicht gestreamt habe
Ich wollte es ja schonmal teststreamen
Wie gesagt ich habe
Soll ich mal meine Playzeit gucken
Hier sind bestimmt zig Schleicher wenn die Flagge auf Hip ist
So wir machen jetzt mal hier
Schönen Domination Task
Da ist schon der erste
Alter
Und er hat auch noch ALTER
Mehr Schleicher zerk
Das ist typisch
Das ist so eine typische
Dark Kacke
Das gibt es eigentlich auch nur in diesem Game
Ich habe es ja schon gesagt
Hier sind ganz viele Schleicher
Das roch schon so danach
Das ist so eine typische Dark Sache
Dass die Schleicher
wirklich ehrenlose Pisser sind
Das ist in dem Game so
Hier ist nichts mit Schleicher
Nice fight one on one
Vergiss es
Hier ist Schleicher zerk angesagt
Also wir können jetzt schonmal rüber porten
Weil der Taskwechsel in 4 Minuten
Und Defend mit Gull ist eh blöd
Vorher muss ich doch mal ein Amulet aufladen
Ja
Machst du noch was auf YouTube?
Ja mach ich
Ich wollte schon ewig mal
ein Video zu meinem neuen Nass machen
Haben wir uns ja hier sogar im Stream
zusammengestellt
Mal zurück porten
Porten Amulet aufladen
Jaja also YouTube
Das Spiel respondet nicht
Jetzt respondet wieder
Erstmal kurz Amulet aufladen
Es wie gesagt
10 Minuten ist aber Neustart
Ich hoffe Lautstärke passt
So von Musik als auch In-Game Sound halbwegs
Ja was gibt es zu dem Game noch zu sagen
Außer dass es für Einsteiger nicht
Nicht
Also auf Phoenix gehts
Ja und ihr findet hier viele Leute zum Leveln
Und viele Leute die das Spiel erklären
Aber das Spiel hat sehr viel
Magic
Sag ich mal dabei
Das ist nicht unbedingt logisch
An vielen Stellen
Du hast so ein paar kleine Sachen zum Beispiel
Was deine Stats angeht
Die sich ab einer gewissen Anzahl nicht mal so
Verhalten wie vorher
Du hast irgendwie
Was gibt es denn da für ein schönes Beispiel
An Dauergeschichten die man nicht
Versteht
Ja zum Beispiel wenn mich einer
CCt mit einem Spell
Hat man eine Minute Immuntimer
Und wenn mich einer mit einem Nahkampf
Angriff CCt ist es das dreifache
Vom Nahkampf Angriff Dauer
So Zeug das kriegst du dem Spiel nicht erklärt
Das muss man wissen mit der Zeit
Die Server laufen nicht
Das ist ein Freeshark
Play Phoenix
Und der Freeshark macht um Längen mehr Spaß
Als live um Längen
Sebarum wir könnten vielleicht ein Kommando machen
Irgendwie Ausrufezeichen Server oder sowas
Falls es nicht schon gibt
Genau und die Jungs hier
Die machen eigentlich das
Was Dauerg auszeichnen sieht zumindest so aus
Die bauen eine ordentliche Achtergruppe
Und
Achter beziehungsweise Gruppen bauen
In Dauerg ist so eine Wissenschaft für sich
Du brauchst immer
Zwei Supporter in Dauerg also sprich hier
Heiler Heiler
Shammy also eigentlich brauchst du drei
Dann brauchst du was mit Speed ganz geil
Dann brauchst du Mehledamage was mit Schild
Also das ist wirklich eine Wissenschaft für sich
Gibt es Plate achja genau
Ich pass mal auf ich zeig euch das von meiner Spielzeit
Die F3 Server
Die kannst du löschen Sebarum
Also Plate das ist schon wieder lächerlich eigentlich
12 Tage 8 Stunden
Oder
Nein
13 Tage 21 Stunden
Plate
Und
Dass es raus
Der Server ist raus gekommen
Am
10. Januar
Also
Ist schon ein bisschen
14 Tage aufgerundet
14 Tage
Oh ne jetzt wird es auch noch Nacht
Dann sieht man nichts
Ihr müsst mir mal sagen ob es zu dunkel wird
Dann mach ich das Gammar ein bisschen hoch
Wobei eh in 5 Minuten Server Neustart ist
Dann ist wieder Tag
Achja und das wichtigste beim Rennen
Ist das Sprengen
Weil
Bros Sprengen in Dark
Das werdet ihr sehen
Also gute Gegner springen immer
Guck mal einem Gegner
Ein Miner der will geowned werden
Damn
Rekt
Flötest du
Oder hast du ein Infi dabei
Damit geflötet
So jetzt warte ich dass meine DDS wieder kommen
Und dann kriegt er einen Seilsteil reingedrückt
Wenn meine DDS da sind
Seilsteil
Jetzt misst er den Seilsteil auch noch
So
Jetzt werde ich einfach mit meinem normalen Steil
Die ganze Zeit draufhauen bis er kaputt geht
Oder bis er irgendwie einen Heal oder so zündet
Dann zünde ich nämlich auch meinen Heal
Aber der Typ sieht nicht so aus als hätte er noch irgendwas
Doch, Heal, zack
Mal auch mal meine Heals rein
Also Miner kann im Prinzip nicht allzu viel gegen Skalde machen
Wie man hier sieht
Außer dass er wild hin und her wackelt
Und nicht einen Tasten drücken muss um ihn zu killen
Also Skalde ist
Absolut easy mode gegen
Rakt
Da ist er down
Heal noch ein Stückchen weg
Da machst du nix
Skalde ist eh eigentlich ziemlich
OP
Dahinten irgendwas
Da kommt Schnitzel
Da vorne kommt Schnitzel
In den Kopf mit Pommes
Bester Name
Das war aus meiner Gilde
Schnitzel wie in der Art mit Pommes
Achja und das ist auch so eine Mechanik in Dark
Songswitchen
Das erzählt dir keiner
Kein Tutorial oder sonst was
Dass du, wenn du Songswitcht
Sprich wenn ich meinen Heilsongswitch und meinen Speedsong
Lass die sich kurz überlappen können
Also sprich ich lass den an
Und jetzt geht erst Speed weg
Das heißt wenn ich die schnell wechsle habe ich beide
Genauso wie bei den Resistenzen
Die kann ich auch einfach
Alle anmachen
Wenn man sie auf Makro bindet oder so
Wie gesagt
Also die Details sind nicht so ohne
Ich werd invaitet aber ich bleib mal solo
Hallo
Mal in 3 Minuten den Server Neustart
Geht aber immer schnell
Oh Sebaro nice
Und wie weit bist du schon
Ist zu dunkel oder soll ich
Soll ich gamma
Ich mach gamma ein bisschen hoch nach dem Server Neustart
Sonst zu dunkel
Weil eins was wir sagen
Fackel machen nur Noobs an in dem Spiel
Weil Fackel
Ich weiß nicht ob ich es hier sehe
Ob hier irgendein Dude mit Fackel hier rumläuft
Weil Fackel siehst du
5km gegen den Wind
Dass da irgendein Gegner ist
Guck die haben alle Fackel aus
Der Typ hier hinten könnte Fackel an haben
Der leuchtet so
Ich glaub der
Ich glaub der hat Fackel an
Nee der hat keine Fackel an
Der hat einfach eine helle Rüstung
So noch 2 Minuten bis Server Neustart
Wir rennen jetzt einfach mal
Zu den Gegnern und killen noch 1-2
Und wippen uns und loggen wieder neu ein
1 Sebaro
Hallo
Ja das waren jetzt welche aus Minenrealm
Noch mehr aus Minenrealm
Die sind wieder alle weg
Boah
Welche aus unserer Alli
Ich geh jetzt mal mit denen mit
Übrigens
In Midgard werdet ihr sau viele Trolle sehen
Weil es der beste Nahkampf
Die beste Nahkampfrasse im ganzen Spiel ist eigentlich
Der Gegner gesnarrt
Hallo lasst mir was übrig
Zack, weg
Ähm
Weil du startest mit 100 Stärke
Im Vergleich zum Nordmann
Was ich bin mit 70 oder so
Das ist mega OP
Aber es hat jedes Reich
So eine OP Nahkampfklasse
Alveon hat Halboga, Midgard hat Trolle
Und Hips haben den komischen
Vierbolgdinger
Es hat aber so einen Grund warum ich keinen Troll genommen hab hier
Weil ihr seht wie fett solche Trolle sind
Das heißt ich kann mich auch
Zum Beispiel hinterm Baum verstecken
Und mich sieht keiner
Wenn ich so fetter Troll wäre
Dann Server Neustart jetzt nicht wundern
Ja Sword Speck
Aber Hammer ist viel besser
Das einzige was Sword hat
Ist ein besserer Timer
Aber Hammer ist viel besser
Aber ich mag Sword Speck
So, ich muss mal neu starten
Server Restart
Server ist nämlich ab
Bin gleich wieder on
Mache eine Controller basierte WLAN Umgebung für eine Schule
Ja es kommt ja
Sebaros kommt ja bei der IHK
Also beim Abschlussprojekt
Kommt es ja gar nicht so sehr darauf ein
Dass man was super kompliziertes macht
Sondern
Dass man alle Aspekte abgedeckt hat
Die die IHK sehen will
Ja zum Beispiel dass du eine Analyse gemacht hast
Was es kostet
Dass du eine Produktauswahl gemacht hast
Server Reboot
Und
Die hat aber lange die Augen auf
Ja das Bild ist von gestern Abend
Ah, nein immer sauber geht immer noch nicht wieder
Ja, jetzt kann ich ja mal nachgucken
Wann Dog rausgekommen ist
Solange das Rebootet
Und
Also rausgekommen ist das Game 2001
Also sprich das ist 18 Jahre alt
Ja in Europa ist ein bisschen später rausgekommen
Goa
Einer der unfähigsten
Läden
Die ich je gesehen habe
Also was die alles verkackt haben
Ist echt der Wahnsinn
Und
Also ich hab früher
Gespielt auf
Für die Leute die
Vielleicht auch mal auf Live gespielt haben
Mal gucken ob es wieder geht
Geht
Ja geht wieder
Ich hab früher gespielt auf Stonehenge Albion
Und auf Salisbury Midgard
Und auf Lioness Hip
Und danach noch
Auf wie hieß der Ami Server
Midgard auf dem Ami Server
Ähm
Ne der Ami Classic Server
Als der deutsche Classic also als der EU Classic Server
Tod war
Ähm
Und ich hatte noch nen PG Skalde
Auf Ava mit
Der 20.000 Kills hatte
Also Skalde ist mein absoluter Lieblingschar in dem Spiel
So Moment ich muss mal Server Reboot wegmachen
Äh Server Reboot
Hat sich ausrebootet
Äh da ist ein Gegner gespawnt
In uns drinnen
GG Eats Waffen
Heilsong an
Jetzt mal gucken
Also das Spiel ist wirklich alt
Ähm ach guck mal da Gegner
Hier geblieben hier geblieben
Bleibst du stehen
Äh ich zeig euch genau ich zeig euch jetzt mal die
Spells dass man überhaupt versteht was da
Was da eigentlich passiert
Äh während ich hier mal das ist wie gesagt ja nicht meine Gruppe
Ich steh einfach nur mal dabei rum
Also Spells
Ähm als Skalde hat man 2
2 DDs
Haben ne ziemlich kurze Range von 700
Machen auch nicht all zu viel Damage
Aber ist schon mal ganz gut dass man Range Damage hat
Die sind instant also sprich
Die drück ich und der Gegner kriegt Damage
Da kommen ein paar Wachen
Ähm
Nein
Fuck ich hab die Wache gehütet
Ich muss mal abhauen
Ich hab einfach nur Next Target gemacht
Der Typ war schon Down
Alter Speed
Ok ähm ich verpiss mich mal kurz
Lol
F8 Stick
Ok ähm
Aber ich versteck mich
Erstmal hier vorne weil hier unten sieht man es
Nämlich auf der Map hier unten ist das
Ähm das Grenzkeep
Quasi von den Alps
Und da kommen jetzt relativ viele Alps her
Zumal der Tusk auch hier in diesem Gebiet ist
Wo ich jetzt bin
Haha
Gucken wir mal ob wir vielleicht ein paar
Einzelne noch abfarben können die sich jetzt schon zu früh
Rausgetraut haben also die Wachen sollten
Akro verloren haben mittlerweile
Genau ähm ich hab 2 DDs
Ich zeig gleich die Spells gleich mal
Ausführlich wenn ich gestorben bin
No it's
Bisan UI oder Bisan
It's really good it has all
The Phoenix Features
On the Map
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher was das ist
Ich glaube das ist
Siehste
Bingeblieben
Das ist ein Bogey na ich wusste das ist ein Bogey
Ich wollte nämlich nicht geslammt werden
Also nicht gestunt werden direkt hier vorm TK
Da ist mir zu viel los
Bisan UI has all Phoenix Features
You see the capture point flags
The NPC vendors for
RVR loot
And it has
Last updated it has
Gotten classic icons
In my opinion
Best UI for Phoenix
Ok wir versuchen die Typen jetzt mal ein bisschen wegzulocken
Guck mal da ist schon einer
Grauer
Der Dude da oben
Ob ich mich trauen kann zu zweit
Komm wir probieren das jetzt
Also Taktik ist
Der vordere Dude wird
Gesnared
Der wird gesnared
Der Typ wird gekillt
Der wird gemetzt
Hallo
Fuck ich bin near side
Zu viele Gegner ich muss weg
Zu viele Gegner
Alter
Zu viele
Look at the forums
They have a thread in the support section
With all supported UIs
Was soll ich denn da machen gegen 3 Gegner
Sind 3 50er
Nein die haben kein Speed
Das ist das einzige gute was ich hab
So Heilsong rein
Zwischen zwischendurch
Auf auf auf
Verfolgt mich
Jetzt wollen wir mal YOLO
YOLO hinsetzen
Jetzt kriegt er aufs Maul
Also der Boge ist auf jeden Fall noch am Start
Stop
Und jetzt ein Hit noch
Weg
Okay
Ich weiß nicht ob ich den RR gesnared
Da kommt ja noch einer
Ordis
Auf Ordis hab ich jetzt ja echt Bock
Der wird CC
Der wird in snare gestellt
Und ich hoffe dass ich Speed krieg
Bevor der andere Dude an mir dran ist
Also gegen den Ordi machst du nichts
Wenn der eine ordentliche Rüstung hat
Okay drehen wir mal um
Das ist wie gesagt Speed
Speed ist das wichtigste was du für eine Soloklasse in dem Spiel brauchst
Wo sind sie hin?
Ah da unten
Hat der RR
Ich muss mal gucken was der für ein RR ist
Nee der ist zu hoch
Ich hab Nier
Ich hab Nierside
Also sprich das hab ich keine Ranger mit meinen Spells
Und das hält auch noch so ewig
Was könnte ich denn da machen?
Der kann jetzt nichts machen
Ordi Waffe krieg ich alleine nicht kaputt
Aber da ist was
Ah da ist der Scout
Wegerubbelt bevor die anderen Dudes kommen
Das ist aber gar nicht der Scout
Wegen Level
Bam
Wegen Low Level Ordi
Aber ich muss gucken dass die anderen nicht kommen
Komm Hitte
Hitte, Hitte, Hitte
Ich muss weg
Der war sogar nur blau
Da war es Level 45 oder so
Hier muss man ein bisschen aufpassen
Aber wie gesagt hier unten um die Ecke
Ist das Keep wo die Gegner spawnen
Komm den probieren wir jetzt
Wenn der solo ist probieren wir den jetzt
Kurz heilen
Endo auffüllen
Und jetzt versuchen wir dem ein Stückchen wegzulocken
Mal gucken ob der mitkommt
Ich engage ihn jetzt da
Alter Ordis
Was für Damage machen ey
Und er kann sich heilen
Ordis machst du nix
Ordis machst du echt nix
Das ist echt
Das heißt es ist OP
Ich kann mich jetzt hier hinsetzen
Der braucht eine halbe Stunde bis er zu mir angelaufen ist
Da wäre ich wahrscheinlich eher noch von einem Schleicher gekillt
Oder so
Er hat add
Das ist sehr nice
Ordi hat add
Add ist gut für mich
Lauf mir nach
Lass dir Damage machen von dem Mob
Lass dir
Add
Muss mich wieder verpissen
Ja ist gut
Die wollen mich hier abfangen
Aber das kriegen sie wahrscheinlich nicht gebacken
Und Tschüss
Ich versuch den Caster da hinten nochmal kurz zu killen
Der ist ja 2 hit
Mal gucken ob ich den erwische
Da hinten ist er
Ok Leute
Also Taktik
Wir stellen den Ordi ab
Äh
Vanilla sided
Achtung
Also Taktik ist
Ordi haut mich aus dem Hut raus
Haut mich aus dem Hut raus
Er geht in Mats
Der Typ wird dd'd
Angehauen einmal
Und jetzt hat er keinen Quickcast
Alter der Ordi geht noch ins Sack
Ich probier den jetzt zu killen
Ich hab IP und alles noch ready
Alter was der für Damage drückt
Das ist doch nicht normal
Und ich kann den ja nicht mal matsen
Weil der Immuntimer hat
Ihr könnt IP reinhauen und hoffen
Alter was für Damage
Fuck
Das ist so krass ey
Ich hab mal IP gespart
Das hat eh nix gebracht
Also seit den letzten Patch sind Ordis wirklich heftig
Die haben mittlerweile einen Proc
Einen Healproc wenn du auf sie drauf haust
Plus einen Nahkampf Healproc
Wenn sie dich treffen
Das heißt die Healprocken plus von der Rüstung
Die Healprocken immer
Da machst du nix
Aber ist nicht schlimm
So also ich zeig euch jetzt mal kurz
Die Spells und Sachen
Die man hat
Dass man da vielleicht ein bisschen besser durchblickt
Also das erste was man hier oben hat
Als Gal sind zwei Nahkampf-DDs
Also sprich draufdrücken macht Damage
Easy
700 range ist nicht so weit
700 range ist ungefähr so
Das heißt
Was man als Gal gut machen kann
Dagegen schwere Tanks
Die man im 1v1 nicht packt
Ist einfach die den wegrennen
Dauer zwar ne halbe Stunde aber die können nix dagegen machen
Dann mein
Schwert Any-Timer also sprich
Mein Nahkampfangriff
Den ich immer einsetzen kann
Dann nen Style der nur von der Seite geht
Also sprich ich muss hier so neben dem Gegner stehen
Und dann kann ich es von der Seite machen
Follow-up vom Side-Style
Der den Gegner 60% verlangsamt
Ne
29 Sekunden Mats
Also sprich der Gegner bleibt einfach 29 Sekunden stehen
Und kann nichts mehr machen in der Zeit
Wird durch jeglichen Schaden gebrochen
Also da muss man aufpassen
Wie man es gerade gesehen hat, ich hab den Ordi da kurz
Angeschaut mit
Bin weiter gerannt zum Wizard
War es ein Cover? Ne das war glaube ich
Ein Erdwizard oder so was Merkwürdiges
Der andere Typ
Da kann er kurz für die Zeit
Nichts machen. Die 29 Sekunden klingen
Viel, allerdings geht
Resies
Halbieren das teilweise
Also sprich wenn ich
Man sieht Magic-Type ist Body
In dem Fall und wenn der Gegner hier
Wenn der Gegner hier hohe Body Resies hat
Dann geht schonmal die Zeit weg
Davon, also es sind
Unterm Strich sind es nochmal so 20 Sekunden
Es sei denn auf nen Full-Tank
Da hält es
Keine Ahnung 2 Sekunden oder so
Es gibt nochmal extra Fähigkeiten
Das es kürzer hält
Dann hab ich nen 1500er
1500er Range näher
Was den Gegner verlangsamt
Und noch ein paar Songs die ich quasi instant
Hier durchswitchen kann. Einmal Speed
Das ich schneller laufe, nen Heilsong und ein bisschen
Damage add. Da mach ich 7,5 mehr Schaden
Wenn ich nahkampfmäßig drauf hau
Das wars im Prinzip
Also Skalde hatten nicht so viele
Fähigkeiten. Wenn man sich das
Mit nem Hexer anguckt oder
So Bade oder sowas
Irgendwelche Klassen die haben hier drei Leisten voll mit
Mit allem
Serenis Max Dark ist auch übelst unverständlich
Deswegen ich versuch es irgendwie so weit
Zu erklären wie es irgendwie geht
So die nächsten
Die nächsten Leisten sind eigentlich nur Buffs
Einmal Buffdrank
Für Mana Regeneration
Lebensregeneration
Ausdauer Regeneration. Ausdauer ist das da
Das gelbe, Lebens ist das rote
Dann ein Buffdrank
Mit Stärkebuff
Geschicklichkeitsbuff
Schnelligkeitsbuff, Stärkebuff, Intelligenzbuff
Blablub. Braucht man wenn man solo spielt
Sonst kannst du es vergessen
Haste, schneller angreifen, Drank
Ja Blockwatcher
Das Spiel ist ja auch von 2002
Die untere Leiste ist
Quasi nur RAs
Ganz grob gesagt
Es sind auch ein paar Charges von Items
Ein Heal-Item, ein Heiltrank
Und meine vier aktiven
RAs
Die relativ wichtig sind
Das ist ein Heal, den kann ich nur einsetzen außerhalb vom Kampf
Das ist ein Heal, den kann ich im Kampf einsetzen
Allerdings mit 15 Minuten Timer
Das ist Purge
Also sprich wenn mich ein Gegner CCt
Kann ich einmal alle 10 Minuten draufdrücken
Und das CC ist weg
Und SOS, also sprich Speed of Sound 1
Ist im Prinzip
Ähnlich wie Purge, nur dass ich
Einsetzen muss bevor der Gegner mich CCt
Also wenn ich einen Caster sehe
Der auf mich
Zaubert, dann drücke ich das
Und dann wirkt es nicht wenn er auf mich
Zaubert
Das heißt man kann eigentlich
Auch nur ordentlich spielen
Oder solo spielen wenn man
Ein bisschen die Klassen kennt gegen die man
Spielt
Das Task ist jetzt hier in HIP
Das heißt wir sind schon im richtigen Grenzgebiet
Und wir versuchen jetzt mal durchzukommen
Durchzukommen
Vor die Gegner durch die Grenzfestung
Und ein paar Nachzügler abzufangen
Das ist
Sonntagnachmittag
Eher schwer
Weil wir müssen komplett
Durch die Grenzzone hier durch
Und
Einmal rechts ist hier ein Keep
Also eine Festung die man einnehmen kann
Wir machen ab und zu mal Gegner
Von links ist da wo wir gerade eben
Gefightet haben, da kommen die Alps her
Und von rechts
Kommt ein paar Hibis her
Da müssen wir jetzt mal gucken ob wir die
Ob wir die wegkriegen
Das sieht aus wie der Bade, den müssen wir jetzt erstmal
Kurz killen
Meint vor was
Fuck da
Wegen geblieben
Muss erstmal den Truide machen
Guck mal hier
Halbe Mits am Start
Hallo, stehen bleiben
Stehen bleiben
Oh fuck
Leute Mits rennt vor mich, da kommen ganz viele Alps
Ich muss weg
So und das kann man halt als Galda auch schon machen
Man kann die Gegner ganz gut außen
Manövrieren, weil man Sinn verläuft
Und schön reinetten
Das allerwichtigste
Schön reinetten von der Seite
Weißt du wie der Azitoni
Guck der da
Der will weggeaddet werden
Von mir, hat er gesagt
Stehen bleiben
Ach komm
Oh jetzt muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen
Ich brauche ein paar Gegner zwischen mir
Also ein paar Befreundete zwischen den Gegnern und mir
Also die casten mich relativ schnell weg
Besser als 1000 Unreal 3 Engine Klon
Das ist
Die Engine da unten drunter ist
Ihr werdet lachen
Das ist soweit ich weiß
Ganz ganz
Entfernt
Die die unter ähm
Links drunter ist
Und äh
Fallout
Und ich glaube auch unter Elder Scrolls
Allerdings
Ist da nicht mal viel davon zu erkennen
Oh der Mine, der will auch sterben
Nein
Ich muss mal kurz abhauen
Die machen zu viel Damage
Und es sind mir auch zu viele ehrlich gesagt gerade
Ich glaube ich haue mal ab
Ich haue mal ab
Sind mir ein bisschen viele Alps
Die anderen rennen auch schon alle weg
Die dann auch schon weg
Wie viele sind? Da kommen drei Gruppen
Oder sowas gerade
Fuck
Ok Speed an und weg
So wie kommt man da jetzt vorbei?
Da ist jetzt
Da müssen wir jetzt Trick 17 machen
Aber wie viele sind denn das so jetzt?
Was ist mit denen los?
Das Alp zerrt am Start
Rennen wir mal unsere Typen danach
Wir hoffen auch die Alps lassen uns in Ruhe
Ach guck mal da ist ein Gegner
Der will zu den Alps da runter
Der will zum Zerr- oh fuck
Da kommt ne Gruppe
Ihr geht auf Gruppe
Gehe ich vorbei?
Oder helfe ich unseren Dudes?
Ich metze einfach einmal
Und verpiss mich
Mal gucken wie der Fight läuft
Das ist ein Troll Schami das kann nichts werden
Sobald die haben ne Troll Schami dabei
Dann habe ich kein Vertrauen darin
Dass sie den Fight gewinnen
Gut wir nutzen mal die Chance dass die sich jetzt
Kloppen und versuchen mal
Aus dem Gebiet hier rauszukommen
Weil das ist mit Abstand das Gebiet
Wo am meisten los ist
Zumal hier auch noch FVR-Task ist
Also sprich FVR-Task heißt
Flanken zum einnehmen
Bloß für jeden Kill extra Items
Hinter mir kommen wieder zwei
Aber die kommen nicht ran
Eigentlich muss ich links rum
Ich geh jetzt mal hier drüber
Und hoff die sehen mich dann immer
Ach guck mal ne Gruppe
Gruppe?
Wir enden mal mit rein
Leute hau doch nicht ab
Nicht abhauen
Nein
Das ist jetzt schlecht für mich
Ich hab auch keinen Perch oder sonst was
Ich kann mich höchstens noch schnell heilen
Ich muss weg
Lass mich in Ruhe
Ich muss raus hier
Nein ich bin debufft ich bin down
Och Gott ey
Los gerade
Das ist das was ich meine
Es ist halt dynamisch
Auf der einen Seite der riesen Alpzirk am Start
Läufst du um die Ecke
Hast ne Gruppe Midis fighten
Wo dann das andere Reich rein erdet
Also es ist ziemlich schwierig hier durch
Es ist zu dunkel
Soll ich ein bisschen Gammar hochschrauben
Also ich mach mal hier nichts daraus
In diesem Raum
Wo ich dann
Diesen Eintritt
Äh in
Das sind alle Spieler jaja
Ja das macht sie ja gerade auch so cool
Alle Spieler
Darf ich mein Buff mal zünden
Please
Weg doch lieber Hammer
Hammer ist eindeutig der bessere Speck
Aber Hammer hätte mich jetzt auch nicht gerettet
Aber du hast recht
Hammer ist eindeutig der bessere Speck
Aber ich mag Hammer nicht
Das liegt einfach daran
Ich hab auf live damals auch Schwert gespielt
Und irgendwie gefällt mir Schwert besser
Nichtsdestotrotz Hammer ist
Eindeutig der bessere Speck
Da gibt es nichts zu diskutieren
Ähm
Das einzige was Schwert
Hat ist den besseren Anytime
Und auch nicht
Wirklich viel
So
Ich werd erstmal was weggezergt hier
Zack
Hier stehen bleiben
Stehen bleiben
Zztztztzt
Ja
So sieht es in der Augen aus wenn man gemetzt ist
Man muss über dem Kopf blinken und kann sich nicht bewegen
Was ziemlich langweilig ist
Aber
Was die einzige Möglichkeit ist
Dass man mit 8 Leuten gegen mehr gewinnt
Und das sind übrigens alles echte Spieler hier
Also ihr habt heute
Wir haben heute einen guten Tag erwischt eigentlich
Dass man mal ein bisschen Dark R4R zeigt
Weil
Sonntag ist auch schon um die Uhr richtig viel los
Alter komm her
Geblieben
Geht
Und jetzt
Zack
Entschreckt
Wir bleiben jetzt mal kurz bei unserem Zerg
Dass wir durch die Zone durchkommen
Das sind alles echte Spieler
Das ist auch das was Dark R4R auszeichnet
Dass wir wir können
Ich guck mal kurz wieviel
Also aktuell sind 150
Nur in diesem Grenz
Nur in dieser Karte hier gerade 150 Midis
Und ich würde mal sagen
Wahrscheinlich von den anderen reichen ungefähr auch noch mal
Jeweils 150
Also macht dann Quick Muffs
Macht dann 450
Spieler gerade in dem Gebiet
Deswegen kommt man da auch so schlecht durch
So
Jetzt muss man ein bisschen aufpassen
Man darf den Gegner nicht
Hier sind Alps auf der Seite
Und hier ist jetzt ein Hip Fight
Das ist jetzt schwierig wo man drauf geht
Und man darf zumindest als Solo Spieler nicht zu weit rein
Das ist das wichtigste
Erstmal warten bis die eigentlich Leute drin sind
Und dann kann man
Auch mal ein bisschen ableschen
Oder nicht zu lange
Sondern einfach weiter
Wobei mein Ziel ist ja eigentlich durch das Gebiet durchzukommen
Da oben ist noch mehr
Da oben ist jetzt
Da oben sind jetzt Hips am Start
Ist aber gerade echt viel los
Guck mal
Jetzt haben wir alle drei Reiche auf einem
Auf einem Haufen
Im Prinzip jeder gegen jeden
Und vor allem wild
Ist jeder gegen jeden rumgezerrgelt
Vielleicht haben wir jetzt einfach mal eine Chance
Dass man durchkommt
Ok wir versuchen jetzt mal auf mir durchzukommen
Ich mach sogar mal Lampe an
Also meine Rennen nach da unten
Also
Es gibt leider nur einen Ausgang aus dem Gebiet
Zwei, linke Schlucht, rechte Schlucht
In der Regel ist linke Schlucht besser
Da vorne kommt schon wieder irgendwas
Ich hab's gar nicht richtig gesehen
Ich hab nur den Kopf gesehen
Das sah aus wie diese komische Hip Gruppe
Die irgendwie in rot und schwarz immer rumläuft
Ok versuchen wir mal rechte Schlucht durchzukommen
Gucken wir mal was wir da schaffen
Wobei linke Schlucht ist besser
Linke Schlucht ist deutlich sicherer normalerweise als rechte Schlucht
Weil hier oben
Hier oben ist eigentlich so die Autobahn
Wo alle Achtergruppen langlaufen
Oder hier in der Mitte eins von beiden
Ich war ja früher auch
Klühender Achtergruppenverfechter
In dem Spiel
Wenn ich jetzt ganz hier oben am Maprand laufe
Hab ich vielleicht Glück und komm vorbei
Wenn es die Gegner nicht auch machen
Während ich versuche hier mal durchzulaufen
Kann ich noch mal kurz was zu den Spells sagen
Man hat nämlich auch eine Liste mit Spells
Da sieht man als Skull hat man gar nicht so viel
Allerdings hat jeder Spell eine Daseinsberechtigung
Was bei vielen anderen Klassen nicht unbedingt so ist
Ich meine wer benutzt Live Transfer als Cover
Ich bin Arsch
Ich glaube jetzt kommen wir vorbei ohne Gegner
Der Mob hier unten schockt mich immer
Das sieht immer aus wie ein Gegner
Und ich denke mal die meisten von euch
Wenn schon das eine oder andere MMO gespielt haben
Oder?
Das heißt sowas wie DPS
Oder DD
Oder CC oder sowas ist wahrscheinlich geläufig
Oder?
Ist das ein reines PvP MMO?
Nee
Also du levels ganz normal
Also du kannst
Auf Level 50 levels du hauptsächlich
PvM
Bisschen RVM, machst ein bisschen PvP
Es gibt eine High End
Ein paar
Level 50 High End
PvM Content
Es gibt eine ziemlich schwere
Ziemlich schwere Dungeon
Wo du auch wirklich optimierte Gruppe brauchst
Dass das funktioniert
Plus einige Farm
Farm Dungeons
Oder Farm Gebiete
Zum Beispiel
Ich kann euch gleich nochmal was zeigen wenn wir es haben
Es gibt hier mit Darkness Falls
Ein RVR Dungeon
Wo auch so ziemlich das meiste Geld droppt
Das ist ein Dungeon
Wo quasi alle 3 Reiche rein können
Wo man PvM und PvP gleichzeitig machen kann
So
Ich blick gerade immer durch wo sind wir denn
Ach hier
Und was auch eine Sache
Die ich so in MMOs
Selten erlebe ist
Oder heute noch ist, dass man die Karte kennt
Ich hab hier unten zwar eine Karte aber ich brauch die Karte nicht
Die Karte hat
Insofern gut aufgebaut
Dass sie Locations hat die man sich merken kann
Sprich der Friedhof hier das Keep da
Das Reliquip hier
Das See hier unten dass ich genau weiß wo ich bin
Ich laufe jetzt quasi
Hier am Reliquip vorbei
Wo ich aufpassen muss dass mich die Bachen nicht erwischen
Dann laufe ich hier unten durch
Und dann bin ich direkt an der Grenzfestung
Von den Gegnern
Und krieg vielleicht ein paar Gegner abgefangen
Die ins Grenzgebiet laufen wollen
Weil
Da rumzergen in die Main
Ist ja auch sinnlos irgendwo
Und es ist gar nicht so schlecht dass Nacht ist
Ich hab die beste Tarnung für
Wege
Schwarz, schwarz-silber Tarnung
Auf dem Weg sieht mich keiner
Hä
Die Spieler die gut sind sehen nicht ohne Probleme
So da vorne ist was
Ein grauer Lefler
Ein grauer Elf
Also ich könnte die jetzt umhauen
Das sind alles echte Spieler
Die Sache ist nur das lohnt sich nicht
Krieg ich keine Punkte für
Es sei denn die greifen mich an
Dann hau ich so um
Aber solange die mich nicht angreifen lass ich sie eigentlich
Krieg ich eh nix für
Außer dass es mich aus dem Speed haut und ich nicht mehr von den Gegnern abhauen kann
So hier muss man so ein bisschen aufpassen
Weil die Gegner kommen eigentlich eher von hier rechts gelaufen
Da vorne ist doch was
Da vorne ist was
Levelgruppe
Mit Pilzen
Zack
So hier drehen wir jetzt mal ein paar Runden
Und gucken ob wir Gegner finden
Müssten wir eigentlich
Wir müssen nur aufpassen
Alles grau
Weil wir uns keine Gruppe erwischt
Gleich wirds
Naja fast gleich wirds auch wieder hell
Mal gucken wie lang noch task ist
30 Minuten ok passt
Rauer Elf suche Gegner
Blitz
Oh muss weg
Da war ne ganze Gruppe
Ich weiß nicht ob ihrs gesehen habt aber
Ganze Gruppe
Was war denn da rechts
Ahh
Ein gelber Elf
Und die anderen
Und die Hips sind weg
Der wird jetzt gebashed
Direkt
One Hit
Der hat einen heftigen Crit abgekriegt
Der hatte keine Resis
Er hat einen ordentlichen Crit abgekriegt
Oh meine Buffs laufen aus
Mal kurz rebuffen
Ich muss mal kurz Damage gucken
Sieht man das? Hab ich das Bild drüber?
Ne
Also
560 für Benny Timer
Und dann noch die DDs
Hallo
Moment
Gar keine DDs mehr
Ach hier 200
200 und einmal Nahkampf
Oh der hatte keine Resis
Der war aber auch noch 45 oder sowas
Wie viele Spieler sind auf dem Server unterwegs?
3000 ungefähr
Was eigentlich schon fast zu viel
Das wie man vor allem sonntags sieht
Unter der Woche ist ein bisschen weniger
Was haben wir für Stats?
11k die Stunde, ja da kann ich mit leben
Morgens ist besser
Morgens hat man so 20k RP die Stunde
Da ist was
Graue
Graue Pilze
Sogar graue Pilze sind nervig
Da muss man aufpassen
Achso das sind nicht die Live Server
Die Live Server haben 60 Spieler abends online
Das ist, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Server
Dann siehst du es
Das ist PlayPhoenix
Das ist ein privater Server
Der quasi
Dark genommen hat
Auf dem Stand von vor
So so 2005
Allerdings sehr viele Custom
Änderungen gemacht hat
Also wirklich sau viel, so viel dass man es kaum
Aufzählen kann, da musste man mal den ins Wiki gucken
Also wirklich, das Spiel ist kaum wieder zu erkennen
Guck mal da oben ist was
Hallo
Ein Lefler
Wir lassen erstmal den Mob killen
Und das ist ein Anni
Da muss er dran glauben
Anni sind die nervigste Klasse
In dem ganzen Game
Die können so komische Türme aufstellen
Die dann einfach sinnlos auf alles schießen was vorbeiläuft
Und das war jetzt
Das waren graue Türme
Die haben jetzt schon 20% Schaden gemacht
In 2 Sekunden
RR9 kill Xbox
Red gleich dead
Only Graves, I leave Graves
If you are yellow and X being in front of you
It's your own fault
So, mal gucken ob jetzt hier was kommt, was haben wir da vorne
Graue
Da ist was, aha
Alp
So
Also zuerst den Alp damage machen
Den Alp metzten
Und dann den Lury killen
Und jetzt den Alp killen
So muss was machen
Der minne, der flötet mich jetzt gleich
Macht er nicht
Kann sein, dass wir abhauen müssen, wir haben Ed
Du hör mir zu, ich bin tausend weiter
Ich habe Ed, ich muss weg
Ok, also
Wir rennen jetzt weg, bis wir uns heilen können
Und dann drehen wir um
Lara 10 ist auch noch am Start
Kannste hier mal anklicken please
Ist das noch ein Miner?
Noch ein Miner? Wie viel haben die denn da unten? Ist ja alles voll.
Also das war jetzt ein Bogey und noch ein Gegner, recht noch ein Miner. Ach, super.
Das ist das, was ich halt meine, was das Spiel super dynamisch macht. Dass du einfach drei verschiedene Reiche hast,
die jederzeit überall aufploppen können quasi.
Oder halt mitmachen können.
Da ist was. Da ist was.
Hallo.
Nicht ausweichen, Kollege. Wo sind denn die Midis?
Wo sind denn die Alps?
Ich hab da ein bisschen Schiss vorne, weil
da waren jetzt noch zwei Gegner und ich glaube, die waren auch relativ hohen Rang.
Und mein Heal, mein In-Fight-Heal ist raus.
Okay, da ist noch ein Mid.
Mit dem kann ich da mal vorne gucken.
Hier muss man sich immer ein bisschen konzentrieren.
Ich sende den mal.
Das ist auch so eine Sache,
wo du eigentlich in Dark versuchst, die gelbe Annie mit grauen Pilzen. Okay, da gehen wir mal drauf.
Alter, Annie.
Annie ist mal so krass. Okay, der muss jetzt sterben. Der hat mich angegriffen.
Und jetzt habe ich so nervige 15 Sekunden Seuche drauf. Wollen wir mal kurz warten.
Bis wir abhauen.
Ja, das ist auch so eine Sache, die man in Dark hat, aber nicht in vielen anderen Spielen erlebt,
dass die Leute eine gewisse Bindung zu dem Server haben, zu dem Reich haben und zu den Leuten, mit denen sie zusammen spielen.
Also man lässt hier keine Leute ins offene Messer rennen.
Noch nicht mal die super krass selbsternannten Elite-Typen machen das. Zumal es halt in Dark eh lächerlich ist.
Du hast in Dark so ein paar Leute, die halt so übelst auf Pro machen.
Halt in einem Spiel, was live tot ist und auf dem privaten Server jetzt ein paar Noobs wegrubbeln.
Wo ich fragt werde, wer ist da der Pro und wer der Noob.
Er ist eine gute Fraktion zwischen denen. Ja, es geht, es geht.
Midgard ist ein bisschen zu stark.
Also was die Spieleranzahl angeht, haben wir Midgard ein bisschen mehr als die anderen Reiche.
Dafür sind wir in letzter Zeit nicht sonderlich organisiert.
Ansonsten ist Balance in Dark ein ziemlich schwieriges Thema.
Also man kann nicht sagen, dass die Reiche wirklich gebalanced sind.
Also wenn man jetzt mal von One on One ausgeht, hat jedes Reich Klassen, die ganz gut sind.
Schleicher nehmen sich nicht viel, da sind die Midgard-Schleicher eigentlich am schlechtesten.
Also wenn man mal von Balance ausgeht, was man normalerweise spielt, also quasi Achtergruppe,
da ist Dark nicht so super balanced.
Es gibt zwar Gruppen-Setups für alle Reiche, die halbwegs funktionieren,
aber HIP hat eindeutig die besten Achtergruppen.
Das liegt nicht an den Spieler, das ist einfach von den Klassen, von der Zusammenstellung her.
Dicht gefolgt von Midgard und Albion mit ein bisschen Abstand.
Also Albion ist eigentlich der schwächste Reich.
Und ich bin der Meinung, dass die Entwickler, zumal es hier ein privater Server ist,
Albion ruhig noch ein bisschen was geben könnten, um die Achtergruppen besser zu machen.
Guck mal, da ist ein Gegner, da ist ein Gegner, der levelt.
Ich lass den erstmal hier sein, Mob killen, hau den Mob um, Mob umhauen.
Also alles, was gelb ist, lass ich nicht stehen.
Alles, was gelb ist, lass ich nicht stehen.
Ab gelb bist, ab level 35, du bist zwar One-Hit und bist zwar keine Herausforderung,
aber wer gelb ist und im Grenzgebiet levelt, muss damit rechnen, dass ich ihn umhauen.
Wer grau ist, hat's gut. Grau lass ich in Ruhe. Seine Grau greifen mich an.
Aber Balance ist in Dark nicht so wirklich.
Es ist schwierig. Du kannst in allen Reichen gute Sachen bauen.
Oh fuck, Gruppe muss weg.
Zum Beispiel eine OP-Sache an Hip-Gruppen ist Instant Amnesie.
Die haben eine Klasse, die hatten einen Spell mit 2300er Range,
das heißt, es ist ungefähr so bis da zum Weg von denen gewesen.
Ein instant 2300er Range Spell, der mich aus dem Speed holt.
Das heißt, der sieht mich, klickt mich an und die ficken mich.
Das ist das OPste und Unfährste, was es in dem ganzen Spiel eigentlich gibt.
Es gibt im Forum eine 25-Seiten-Diskussion, irgendwie interessiert es keinen.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die Midgard hat, die andere Reiche nicht haben.
Mehr Nahkampfgeschwindigkeit und sowas.
Aber instant 2000er Range Amnesie 2300er ist das OPste, was es in dem ganzen Spiel gibt.
Und ich, guck mal da, ach, Graue, Graue, Graue.
Okay, Graue, die mich angreifen, da bleibt mir ja nichts anderes übrig.
Welches Level bist du? Ich bin 50 und Reichsrang 8L1.
Das...
Ah, 50 ist mal relativ schnell.
Also wer das mal ausprobieren will, kann ich das wirklich nur empfehlen.
Ihr geht einfach auf Playphoenix, ladet euch das offiziell...
Die haben in ihrem Wiki eine Anleitung, wie es geht.
Ihr macht euch das einfach in den Account, ladet euch das Spiel runter, installiert es
und spielt einfach mal bis Level 50, ob es euch gefällt.
Bis Level 50, das ist das schöne, bis Level 50 kennt ihr eure Klasse.
Das dauert so ungefähr 20 Stunden Play, ungefähr.
Ihr spielt hauptsächlich, ihr spielt am Anfang, machte ein bisschen Solo-Tas
und dann levelt ihr hauptsächlich in Gruppe bis 50, dann holt ihr euch eure Epic-Rüstung ab
und dann könnt ihr ein bisschen rumbasteln, ein bisschen rumprobieren, wie euch die Klasse gefällt.
Also man levelt auf Phoenix relativ schnell.
Und alles, was man hier sieht, ich meine, das hier sind offensichtlich Mops, ja.
Aber nochmal, alles, was man hier sieht, sind Spieler, das hier sind Wachen.
Aber alles, was hier sonst so rumläuft, das sind echte Spieler.
Also das ist nicht zu vergleichen mit irgendwelchen anderen Spielen, wo da NPCs oder sowas am Start sind.
Alles hier echte Spieler, die da rumstehen.
Und hier muss ich aufpassen, hier war eben noch der Minne und der Boogie am Start.
Wo bekommt man auf Phoenix-Tasks, du gibst ein Slash-Task-Personal, dann kriegste das da angezeigt.
Und da hast du einmal Kill-Tasks, also sprich, du musst Mops killen von diesem Typ, kriegste Punkte.
Du kriegst diese.
Probier es mal.
Das sind Graue, die lasse ich eigentlich stehen, aber man, was willst du machen, da sind Gelbe dabei.
Was willst du machen?
Ich fühle mich schlecht, Leute.
Ja, ich fühle mich schlecht, ist gut, ich habe Ex-Pa gekillt.
Das sind vier, ist zu viel.
Das ist nicht sonderlich schwer, da muss man jetzt auch nicht stolz drauf sein, dass man Ex-Pa killt.
Aber die waren Gelb und Gelb ist RIP.
Weil ich kein Partner bin, immer noch nicht.
Genau, wie gesagt, du kannst die Personal-Tasks machen.
Du kriegst für jeden gekillten Gegner die Phoenix-Eier, die du abgeben kannst.
Ja, gab es sonst noch irgendwas? Ich habe es schon wieder voll vergessen, wie das mit Leveln ist.
Aber das reicht, da bist du in null Komma nix, bist du Level 30, saumäßig schnell bist du Level 30.
Danach suchst du dir einfach eine Gruppe. Machst ein bisschen DF, wenn es offen ist, dass du Geld kriegst.
Und mit 50 machst du deine Epic, geht auch schnell zwei Mops killen.
Dann hast du für Level 50 eine ganz gute Rüstung und ein bisschen Geld und schon ein paar Drops.
Du kannst zumindest schon mal loslegen.
Oh oh, ich bin down. RIP.
Da kann man nichts machen, da haben sie mich überrannt.
Manchmal hat man Pech, manchmal kann man nichts machen.
Manchmal kann man nichts machen. Wir können mal gucken, ob wir ein Teleport haben.
Hast jahrelang da auch gezockt? Also auf Phoenix ist es ein bisschen anders.
Ach, der Choice hat es gesehen, da ist...
Irgendwie fühlt es sich wundern, wenn die sogar... vielleicht haben die sogar Stream-Sniped, aber man weiß es nicht.
Wir haben kein Port, vielleicht kriegen wir gleich ein Port.
Also diese Fahnen, die ihr da gesehen habt, die man einnehmen kann, kann man quasi als Nachschubpunkte verwenden.
Wo man alle 100 Sekunden hinporten darf.
Das heißt, wenn wir Glück haben, haben wir jetzt das eingenommen.
Und wenn wir noch mehr Glück haben, darf ich dann 70 Sekunden hinporten.
Wenn wir Glück haben.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt mal kurz 60 Sekunden hier rumrennen.
In der Hoffnung, dass ich porten darf. Wenn nicht, muss ich wieder durch das Gebiet laufen.
Genau, also Hanyal, du kannst...
Mach die Task personal.
Das bringt richtig was und gibt die Phoenix-Eier ab.
Ansonsten, glaube ich, gab es nichts mehr.
Aber das bringt saumäßig viel extra. Also du bist grad fast Level 30.
Und ich würde dir halt empfehlen, nimm als erstes eine Klasse, aber das ist dir wahrscheinlich klar.
Die halt auch ganz gut in Gruppe ist.
Einfach für eine erste Klasse ist...
Also wenn man anfängt, sollte man eine Klasse nehmen, die irgendwie in Gruppe passt.
Also sprich, man sollte nicht gerade jetzt den Schleicher spielen.
Ich meine, Schleicher kriegen ab und zu auch mal eine Gruppe, aber sie bringen der Gruppe nichts, deswegen werden sie kaum in Gruppe genommen.
Okay, porten und ganz schnell weg. Ganz schnell weg hier.
Was kommt denn da? Was ist denn das?
Land Hilde ist das. Ah ja.
Und, wer läuft da hinterher? Ich habe sie angeklickt.
Die laufen einen ziemlich risikoreichen Weg hier.
Aber zu dritt ist auf jeden Fall erst mal safer als allein.
Ah, guck mal. Den kenne ich.
Der Jäger.
Der einzige, den ich auf dem Server kenne, der was kennen kriegt.
Bersi. Ja, Bersi ist so...
Kann man in Gruppe nehmen, muss man aber nicht unbedingt.
Also wurde, also was hier auf Phoenix halt recht optimiert ist, sind halt die Levelgruppen.
Also, es gibt, es gibt für alles Levelgruppen, aber es gibt recht viele optimierte Levelgruppen.
Einfach weil das Spiel 20 Jahre hat, dass die Leute halt wissen, wie man spielt.
Das heißt...
Mit sowas wie Shammy, Heiler, Bombe...
Ja, genau, also das, was du gerade geschrieben hast.
Krieger, Krieger mit Schild.
Krieger ist auch sehr beliebt in Gruppe.
Hallo, Juni was? Geht.
Oh fuck ey, was war das, was war das? Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ich hab's nicht gesehen, was war denn das? War das Hips?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Und wahrscheinlich war das Hips ne Gruppe.
Oder? War das ne Gruppe? Ja, das war ne Gruppe Hips.
Was soll sonst gewesen sein?
Achja, übrigens in dem Game, du kannst jede Steigung hochlaufen.
Außer, außer, außer, außer...
Du kannst jede Steigung hochlaufen.
Außer, außer 90%, 90% bleibste hängen.
Ansonsten kannst du alles easy hochlaufen.
Aber es gibt Falldamage, deswegen muss man hier ein bisschen,
bisschen langsam runterlaufen.
Hallo Klugscheißer.
War da hinter mir was?
Hier laufen die Hips immer lang, da muss man ein bisschen gucken.
Oder?
Ja.
Das ist eigentlich der risikoreichere Weg, den ich hier laufe.
Besser ist außen rum.
Also hier rum.
Weil hier laufen die ganzen...
Entweder laufen die Kuppen hier oder vorne lang.
Eins von beiden.
Deswegen ist hier hinten eigentlich relativ safe.
Die anderen wären glücklich, weil du sie die Beine ziehst.
Und du glaubst du wärst der Einzige, den sie siehst.
Du kannst, ja das stimmt schon, kannst jede Steigung hochlaufen.
Aus dem Paradies.
Du bist nicht allein.
Wir sind Legionen und wir wären bei dir.
So, mal gucken, ob wir sehen, was es ist.
Du bist nicht allein.
Hopp.
Da sind Graue wieder.
Schauen wir, was da oben ist.
Man muss halt ein bisschen aufpassen.
War da was am Hang?
Annie oder so?
Man muss halt hier ein bisschen aufpassen, dass man nicht direkt
Direkt in Sicht der Gegner vorbeiläuft
Jetzt winken die Leute
Wahrscheinlich gucken wir auch ein paar Steam, das ist ja witzig
Was ist denn hier los?
Alter, kannst du dir mal anklicken?
Kälte?
Okay
Zack, gehen wir jetzt drauf
Der hat Damage gefressen, oh fuck
War doch nicht
Von was hat er Damage gefressen?
Ah, der Mine
Der Mine
Und wie viele Alps sind dahinter noch?
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Bleib so stehen
Der Mine, der flirte klein
Wenn der flirte, muss ich da hart umdrehen
Ola, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed
Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed
Hau ab
Piss dich, Alde
Ah, fuck
Dachte ich kann jetzt noch schnell
Turnen und den unhippen
Weil seine anderen
Mates weit weg sind
Oh, Gelbe
Aber die engage ich jetzt nicht
Link
Nice, nice, nice, nice
Bleibst du hier? Bleibst du hier?
Hat er gerade alles resisted?
Kann es sein?
Nice, Heeres
Die anderen kommen, die anderen kommen
Wir sind weg
Wenn du geregt bist, schreib mal
in den Chat
Dann machen wir die platt
Obwohl, das sind drei, vergiss es
Oder? Komm
Nee, nee, da kann ich nicht drauf
Das ist zu viel
Das sind zu viele Gegner
Da machen wir auch nichts, die sind grau
Die Animation, Eaxia
Die Animation sind richtig mies
Ist halt Animation von 2000
Da kommt was drin
Gelber
Flo
Gelber Keltors
Alter
Die ganzen, nicht grau
Die ganzen grünen
Kann ich nicht sagen, ich drück mich vor den großen
Klingel auch immer aufs Maul
Oder ich, je nachdem
Ihr müsst jetzt echt aufpassen
Wenn da drei Alps rumrennen
So, mal schauen, was die Alps
Für Nachschub haben
Nee, krimm, was die brauchen, bis sie da sind
Vor allem, na, das sind Minel
Ja, mit zwei Minel
Oh, fuck, da unten sind sie
Und da kommt ne Gruppe Hips, ich muss weg
Nix wie weg
Vielleicht kann ich die umlaufen
Und irgendwie in die Hips ziehen
Oder so
Nee
Sieht nicht so aus
Da läuft wieder was Gelbes
Hallo
Oh, oh, oh, nee, nee, nee, Kollege
So
Das ist ein BM
Nee, das ist
Keine Ahnung, ist das BM Epic?
Könnte BM sein
Auch Leute
Pisst euch mal
Pisst euch, Alter
Tja
Jetzt mal ehrlich Leute, habt ihr im Stream geguckt
Dass ich da hinten rumgräbse
Weil ihr wart eigentlich schon weg
Ja, also
Da hat man es jetzt gesehen
Muss Verzögerung
Ja, aber das Problem ist, mit Verzögerung reinmachen
Mir ist wichtiger, dass ich ordentliche Chat-Interaktion ab
Als Verzögerung
Scheiß drauf
Da werde ich halt geschneibert
Minimap zensieren bringt nichts
Das ist so ne Sache in Dark
Jemand der das Spiel gespielt hat
Du kannst mir vom gesamten Gebiet in Dark
Jetzt mal hip außen vor
Du kannst mir von Gesamt Midgard, Gesamt Albion
Inklusive Grenzgebiet
Zwei Sekunden in Screenshot zeigen
Ich sag dir wo es ist
Jetzt ohne Witz, das ist
Minimap zensieren bringt gar nichts
So, ich bilde mir ein, ich hab da hinten gerade links was laufen sehen
Das könnte
Nein, das ist Nuts
Hopp
Da rennen wir jetzt mal
Bisschen im Zerg rum, falls wir hier noch einen Zerg haben
Fast vier Minuten, das lohnt sich eh nicht mehr hinzulaufen jetzt
Bersi
Bersi ist finde ich
Im RVR natürlich ne super Geschichte
Vor allem im Group
PvM Leveln ist schwierig
Wenn Bersi
Da würde ich als ersten Char wahrscheinlich eher einen Krieger spielen
Aber wichtig ist ja auch, dass der Char
Einen Spaß machen muss und Bersi ist auf jeden Fall auch
Spielbar im PvM, so ist es nicht
Das bringt ja nichts wenn man sich den Char erstellt
Auf den man keinen Bock hat
Weil das alles nur Natur ist
Na Moment, das ist das eine Grenzgebiet
Was halt hier so grün ist
Die anderen sehen schon anders aus
Also du erkennst meistens
Innerhalb von paar Sekunden
Wenn du eine Screenshot siehst in Dark
In welchem Reich das ist und auch ob es Grenzgebiet ist
Oder
Mainland
Soll ich euch mal
OBM heißt
Soll ich euch mal den RVR Dungeon zeigen
Weil das ist auch so
Eine Sache die ich so in der Form
Noch in keinem anderen Spiel gesehen hab
Und falls ihr anfangt
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch was wo ihr eine Weile drin
Verbringen werdet und leveln
Gibt es auch andere MMOs die dich interessieren
Also ich hab viele
MMOs gespielt
Allerdings in letzter Zeit nichts mehr
Und was mich aktuell interessiert
Ist eigentlich Camelot Unchained
Also quasi der geistige Nachfolger
Um mehr oder weniger
Falls der irgendwann mal rauskommt
Was ist denn da vorne los
Alpsjagd
Machen die schon wieder alle hier
Wo vor allem
Wo sind meine Leute alle hin
Bist du das Mann
50 Milliarden Alps
Vielleicht kann man die umlaufen
Alps haben ja die Angewohner dass sie eigentlich
Nicht sonderlich helle sind
Hallo, wo ist er
Wo ist der Scout
Der Scout schießt mich jetzt an
Fuck ich muss weg
Das war ziemlich bescheuert
Rein stehen bleiben
Lauf
Lauf Lauf Speed Speed Speed Speed
Alter Speed geh an
Scheiße war das knapp
Lauf
Ich setz mich mal hin
Hier ist saumäßig schwierig
Durchzukommen
Aber trotzdem 10 Grad die Stunde
Für Sonntagabend ist das echt in Ordnung
Ist auch
Viel los gerade
Task in HIP ist vorbei
Das heißt als nächstes ist Task
In Albion, dann gehen wir schon mal nach Albion
Und ihr werdet jetzt sehen
Die Grenzgebiete unterscheiden sich total
Das hier war jetzt
Viel Bäume, Luft und Liebe
Und Grün
Verliert man eigentlich Loot Geld wenn man stirbt
Nee du verlierst beim Heiler
Quatsch vergiss das, nee gar nichts
Wenn du PvM stirbst musst du beim Heiler
Ein bisschen Gold bezahlen dass der dein
Leben wieder herstellt aber ist auch nicht viel
Nee du verlierst nichts
Das einzige
Das einzige was du verlierst
Ist bisschen Haltbarkeit auf
Deine Rüstung was dich in Grenzen hält
So das war jetzt
HIP Grenzgebiet, jetzt gehen wir mal nach Albion
Da sieht man gleich das sieht komplett anders aus
Und ich finde das
Albion teilweise
Das eine Map zumindest
Das hässlichste Grenzgebiet ist
Weil es aus so vielen Hügeln besteht
Übrigens wir können jetzt gleich mal was skillen
Ich hab nämlich noch ein
RR also noch ein
Wie heißt das überhaupt
RA Punkt
Ich weiß nicht mehr wie das heißt
Ein Realm Point heißt das glaube ich
Noch frei
Und dann geht man nämlich zum Trainer
Also wie gesagt ich bin Level 50
Das kann ich nicht
Achso übrigens die Spec falls es dir mal interessiert ist
50 Songs 48
18 Parier 39 Schwert
39 Schwert reicht
Weil und das ist auch wieder so eine Dark Geschichte
So eine Dark Magic Geschichte
Die man
Die man wissen muss oder halt nicht
Weil halt Dark weil man
In Dark weil man das
Man weiß es halt einfach nicht gibt kein Tutorial wo das erklärt wird
Das wichtigste ist in Dark
Dass man seinen Waffenskill auf Level 50
Das kann allerdings
Auch durch plus Items
Durch plus Skill passieren
Also sprich wenn ich 39 in Waffens
Waffensbacke also 39 Schwertsbacke
Und jetzt plus 18 Skill kriege
Reicht das dicke aus
Man trifft ein bisschen besser
Danach noch also es ist nicht so dass es komplett
Sinnlos ist
Aber 39 plus 18 reicht
Stimmt auf Phoenix sind es zwei
52 auf
51 genau
Und
Deswegen ist es besser
Man haut beispielsweise noch mehr
Punkte in die Skilllinie rein
Wo man wo man ordentliche Spells kriegt
Was bei mir halt Battle Songs ist weil ich bin halt
Speedklasse
Musikstelle ist
So und jetzt können wir es
Also ich hab noch eine A-Punkt frei
Nee auf live war es nicht 51
Das ist nur eine A-Punkt
Das ist nur Phoenix 52
Auf live bin ich mir eigentlich ziemlich
Sicher dass es 51 war
Es war Level durch 2 plus 1
Und auf Phoenix ist es aus irgendwelchen Gründen plus 2
Weil es eigentlich auch wurscht kann auch auf live 52 gewesen sein
Aber ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher dass es auf live 51 war
Also wir können jetzt ja nicht
Okay
Ja kann auch sein
Also ich mein wir können uns jetzt nichts großartiges kaufen
Ich hab nämlich nur einen Punkt übrig
Das heißt
Viel
Viel geht da nicht ja
Also mehr Damage kann ich nicht kaufen
Würde drei Punkte kosten
Ich kann also ich kann nicht wirklich viel kaufen
Aktive Rs kann ich auch nicht kaufen
Mit einem Punkt also würde ich sagen
Kaufen wir jetzt noch einmal
Parry
3% mehr parieren
Warum nicht
So wirklich bringen
Tut uns jetzt eigentlich nichts
Keine Ahnung
Parry
Mit 8l5
Respec ich eh wieder
Dann gibt es da noch ein bisschen Damage
Und ihr seht schon das Grenzgebiet sieht
Wieder komplett anders aus
Task ist jetzt gewechselt
Task ist jetzt in Albion
Eine Stunde lang
Und
Man sieht schon das sieht halt
Anders aus
Das Grenzgebiet ja also Albion ist eher braun
Braun und ein bisschen Schnee
Hier unten sind immer Schleicher am Start
Also eigentlich gut wie immer
Da vorne rennt auch schon irgendwas was war denn das
Was war denn das
Wird wahrscheinlich ein Skalte gewesen sein
Aber man weiß ja nie so genau
Da ist was
Stehen bleiben
Warte stehen bleiben
Einfach Facen
Wenn man nicht weiter weiß
Und jetzt muss man den Bade interruppen
Sonst heilt der Bade
Alter Midis mach doch mal was
Wollt ihr mich verarschen
Interruptet mal den Bade
Wir müssen jetzt den Bade killen
Alter
Der Dude geht mir auf den Sack
Ich glaube es nicht er
Halt mich einer please
Halt mich einer please ich bin auf 0 TP
Auf 0
3 1 Halt mich keiner
Der Bade stand nicht mal in mein Ziel
Haben sie rausgehauen
Null
Das ist übrigens eines der besten Duos
die du in hip so machen kannst
Also falls auch einer denkt
Er würde gerne mit einem Freund anfangen oder so
Das Spiel ist
eigentlich
Entweder spielt man das halt in einer Gruppe
Oder man spielt Duo Trio
Das ist eigentlich noch viel besser
als alleine
Weil viele Klassen einfach
viel besser sind
Also wie soll ich das erklären
Also zum Beispiel ein Heiler ist halt solo scheiße
Aber
Sobald du den im Team spielst
Bist du quasi mit einem Heiler
nicht einfach nur doppelt so gut
Wie die zwei Charaktere allein
Sondern dreimal so gut, weil du einen Support dabei hast
Und es gibt in dem Spiel
richtig gute Duos, die man spielen kann
Oder Trios, die sich anbieten
Wenn man mit Freunden spielen will
Und unabhängig vom Reich
Also ich würde sagen in Midgard
Ist das beste Trio, was du machen kannst
Entweder Skald, Heiler, Bone Dancer
Alternativ
Duo würde ich sagen
Skald, Bone Dancer
Also als Duo Skald, Bone Dancer oder als Trio
noch ein Heiler dabei
Alternativ anstatt zum Heiler geht auch ein Shami
Wobei ich einen Heiler besser finde
Weil Buff Tränke hat man hier eh
Oder man kann auch anstatt dem BD
Und wenn man auf Nahkampf steht mehr Damage machen
Indem man da
So stehen
Indem man noch einen Savage und einen Wilde oder so einpackt
Aber das
In Midgard, das OP Trio schlechthin
dürfte eigentlich Skald, Heiler, Bone Dancer sein
Falls man mit
Freunden spielen will
Falls ihr Hip spielen wollt
Kann ja sein, dass einer auf Grün steht
Dann eigentlich immer
Bade plus X
Ist eigentlich egal was
Bade, Blademaster
Badefiern
Bade, Badeschnitter, ist eigentlich egal
Du kannst auch Bade
Bade, Entsch
Und in Alp gibts eigentlich
Was auch
Was kannst du in Alp spielen?
Mine Necro?
Mine Necro, also
Mine Sänger und Totenbeschwörer
Find ich das unterschätzte Duo im ganzen Game
Wenn nicht sogar das beste
Also
Mine Necro ist übelst gut
Es spielt bloß irgendwie kaum einer
Oder halt so der Klassiker
Mine Hexe, Clary oder sowas
Also wenn man keinen Bock hat alleine
Anzufangen
Man kann ziemlich gute Gruppen bauen
Zu zweit und zu dritt
Richtig gute Gruppen, also Skald, BD ist auch
Krass OP
So wir versuchen jetzt mal hier
Eine Fahne einzunehmen
Wollen wir das hinkriegen
Also Skald, BD ist wirklich übel nice
Und Sonntag Mittag
Ist es halt immer so auf dem Server
Es ist halt voll
Huge, Massive, voll
Jetzt ist es voll
Und es ist voll
Wir sind
Graue
Grüne und blaue
Midis, die werden wir nicht viel nutzen
Falls hier Gegner kommen
So wir spielen jetzt mal eine Runde Domination
Mal eine Runde Fahne einnehmen
Was ich immer mache ganz gerne
Ich laufe weiter gegen das Ding
Dass man instant mit Speedway wieder losläuft
Nicht erstmal beschleunigen muss
Und man kann die Kamera drehen
Und sieht dass von hinten irgendwas kommt
Was aber
Ein Midi ist
So und jetzt haben wir die Auswahl
Gehen wir Richtung Alp Grenzfestung
Nach Snowdonia
Gehen wir nach Alp Grenzfestung nach Savage
Oder gehen wir erstmal ein paar Fahnen ablaufen
Fahnen ablaufen bringt jetzt aktuell nur begrenzt was
Weil wir noch nicht genug Items abgegeben haben
Dass wir zu den Fahnen Nachschub
Teleportieren können
Wenn ihr Fragen zu dem GameUp
Schießt los
Heute Test und Erklär Stream
Und eben bei ein bisschen
Leuteumhauer Stream
Wie lange dauert das auf Max Level? Ach das geht
Also auf Phoenix geht es relativ schnell
15-20 Stunden
Wenn man
Das ein bisschen
Sinnvoll macht
Da geht es schon uns
Versuchen wir mal rüber nach Snowdonia zu gehen
15-20 Stunden würde ich sagen
Ansonsten
Wenn du eine Klasse spielst, die nicht so beliebt ist
In Gruppen
1-2 Tage
Also Ingame Tage
Aber da musst du schon langsam sein
Wie gesagt
Es geht auf Phoenix relativ schnell
Zumal du hier auf Phoenix auch gut Solo Leveln kannst
Wenn du willst
Trotzdem ist halt eine Gruppe am schnellsten
Wachen? Alles Wachen?
Übrigens man sieht schon
Alp Grenzgebiet finde ich halt richtig räudig
Das hat so viele Berge, du siehst überhaupt keine Gegner
Das ist halt
Voll witzlos
Ich sag euch jetzt eh
Das wird grausam jetzt
Weil jetzt ist Sonntagabend
Fail
Fahne
Ihr müsst mal aufpassen
Lag
Wenn es Hips eingenommen haben, sind die nicht weit
Vielleicht sogar
Schleicher Action, ich weiß es nicht
Aber Sonntagabend wird eh
Wieder ätzend
So
Und jetzt
Deswegen, mit dir fight ich jetzt nicht
Ich hab's nicht genau gesehen was es ist
Aber das sah nach Tank aus
Und Tank auf dieser Entfernung
Als Gald ist keine so gute Idee
Slam, Bam
Speer in Arsch
Und man ist down
Zumal ich auch keinen Perch mehr die hab
Da liegt ein toter
Highlander rum
Da unten ist ein
Konu, das ist ein Jäger oder?
Nee
Ok, jetzt
Oh fuck, ein Necro
Guck schon wieder alle drei
Reiche auf einmal
Der Necro soll mich in Ruhe lassen
Der Infi wird gesnared
Der kommt mir nicht hinterher
Der vermisst euch
The fuck
Man kann
Necro sein so was
Ok
Ist gut
Kelte
Kelte, geh auf den Necro
Nicht auf mich
Jetzt
Jawoll, die werden jetzt gefickt
Ich sag's
Guck, das ist halt so
Krass an der
Oh man, jetzt kommt noch ein
Ok, sobald ich aus dem Mats komm
Ist Sos raus
Raus, raus, raus
Das ist halt übelst nice, Undor
Das hat sonst kein Game
So dynamisch, als PvP
Und das geht nur, wenn du drei Reiche hast
Nur, wenn du so... Funktioniert das wech
Oh fuck, haben die noch
Ein Bade dabei jetzt?
Ja, check ich's bloß nicht
Jetzt könnt ihr gleich mal den opesten Spell im ganzen Spiel sehen
Weil du Baden nicht abhauen kannst
2300 Range Instant Amnesie
Ich weiß nicht, wer auf die Idee gekommen ist
Dass das fair ist in dem Spiel
Vielleicht kommen wir den aber auch weg
Mal gucken
Wir müssen sie auf jeden Fall heilen dabei
Alter
Wollt ihr mir jetzt echt durch die ganze Zone nachrennen, ihr Lappen?
Guck's dir mal an ey
Wir rennen jetzt durch ein paar Mops durch
Alter, die Lappen ey
Ich fass es nicht
Wir versuchen die jetzt mal an ein paar Mops abzuhängen
Und ich darf mich halt selbst von den Mops nicht hitten lassen
Ist sie weg?
OK
Easy
Oh Gott ey
Lappen-Hippies
Ist da Wahnsinn
Guckt euch das mal an
Die rennen mir durch die ganze Scheiß-Zone nach
Alter
Was ist das?
Komm wir ficken die jetzt zusammen
Auf SK
Und wir ficken die jetzt zusammen
Na, ey warum kriegt der Mats raus?
Was soll das?
Hallo?
Ich hab den...
Ist mein Maus-Dings nicht drin oder was?
Oh ich hab den doch gesnarrt
Oh Mann BD, sag mal was ist mit dir los, kannst du die mal killen?
Ehh
Hickt euch ihr Scheiße, Scheißhilfse
Mann, das Snare eben nicht funktioniert
Das ist so geil, der BD hat nix ab, kein Perch, nix, steht den ganzen Fall drum
Wenn der BD nicht im Netz gestanden wäre, dann hätten wir die gefickt
Übrigens, wie gesagt Bade plus X, also wenn ihr mit Freunden das Spiel spielen wollt
und gerne Hips spielt, Bade plus irgendwas, irgendwas Damage und ihr seid ein super Duo
Was in dem Fall war jetzt Bade BM, also Bade Blademaster, Schwertmeister ist auch übelst
gut, ihr habt ja gesehen, wie schnell der mich weggehauen hatte
Aber die Lappen, wie sie mir durch die ganze Zone nachgerannt sind, haben die sonst nichts
zu tun oder was?
Können wir eigentlich porten?
Snow Entrance können wir porten, ja klar, nein wir können nicht
Wir haben nicht genug Items abgegeben, wir können nicht porten
Na toll
Ja, bestimmt BD war ein Starter Guild, ja ist richtig, da darf man eigentlich nicht
so viel erwarten oder meckern
Äh, hallo, hallo, da war ein Schleich, habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Aber keine so gute Idee mit dem jetzt zu fighten, weil da hinten kommt ne Gruppe Hips angerauscht
Ich hoffe jetzt ja eigentlich, dass noch ein paar mehr Midis da drauf gehen, dass wir
die killen können, aber es sieht nicht so aus
Hallo, kommt her
Hier ist ja auch nichts
Ja, es kann auch andersherum gehen, dass man selbst quasi in seinen Keep zurückgedrückt
wird
Übrigens das, die Wachen, die ownen alles hier
Das sind quasi Wachen, die sind nicht besiegbar, das heißt die können sich nicht in unser
Keep da oben, wo wir spawnen, reinstellen, das wäre zu OP
Und wir uns bei den Gegnern auch nicht
Aber das ne, also das eben mit den Schleichern davor, das war halt wieder typisch da auch,
das ist halt übelst nice
Erst die Alps, der Necro, dann hat man sich quasi indirekt verbündet mit dem Hip jetzt
die Alps zu killen, das ist halt übelst nice und das hat kein anderes Game
Deswegen spiele ich das auch jetzt wieder
Und ich denke halt, das liegt daran, dass es ein Game ist mit drei Fraktionen
Und das ist halt, und sowas geht halt auch nur in einem Game mit drei Fraktionen
Du hast, du hast, wenn sich zwei kloppen, kannst du immer noch, du kannst immer als
Gewinner rausgehen, selbst wenn du in der Unterzahl bist, dadurch dass
Oh fuck ey, naja gut so nicht
Einfach weil die Gegner sich kloppen und du abstaubst
Das ist übelst freudig, was soll ich denn jetzt hier machen?
Was, guck mal, ich seh' den Mann
Ich geh' wieder nach Hip
Geh' hier wieder weg
Geh' wieder nach Hip, wird zu blöd
Ich mein, hier ist, hier, das ist alles voll
Zwei bis drei Gruppen Hip und keine Mits am Start
Da warst du nix ey
Vielleicht können wir hier noch ein paar Schleicher ableetschen oder so
Das ist aber immer schwierig so, also Sonntag Mittag ist halt sehr sehr voll
Da, also Sonntag Mittag ist generell Solo schwierig
Und irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, dass gerade Sonntag Nachmittag die Midis total unorganisiert
sind
Mittag Nachmittag, ja für mich ist es abends um 20 Uhr
Ab abends geht's wieder ab, ab abends ist dann ein riesen Midi-Zerk am Start
Ich könnte euch jetzt ja mal kurz den RVR Dungeon zeigen
Was, was wollen wir machen, soll ich zurück nach Hip und noch ein paar Hibis killen oder
soll ich euch mal den RVR Dungeon zeigen?
Ich mein, viel RVR wird das nicht sein, weil wir schon seit einer ganzen Weile wahrscheinlich
den Dungeon
Ach nee, ich kann euch den RVR Dungeon gar nicht zeigen, wir haben ihn gar nicht
Okay, ich vergess das
Komm, wir laufen noch mal ne Runde hier
Ich seh viele, ich seh viele Midkills in die Main, wir gehen auch mal wieder nach die Main
Äh, was für ein Keyboard, ein Corsair
Äh, Cebaro, haben wir da irgendein Kommando für, für Hardware?
Corsair, RGB, Platinum, 50 oder irgendwie sowas, da steht ihr leider nicht drauf, da steht
bloß Corsair drauf
Ich muss jetzt mal bei Amazon nachgucken, wie das hieß
Was macht das Schwert, 100%
Guck mal kurz, ähm, Corsair
Corsair
Platinum
K95
Corsair K95 RGB Platinum Mechanical Gaming Tastatur
Hauptsache langer Name
Guck, hier stehen die ganzen NiceFighter rum
NiceFighter sind für mich die Leute, die optimierte Achtergruppen bauen und halt so
besonders fanatisch teilweise auch andere Achtergruppen suchen und sich über alles
aufregen, was anders spielt
Ich war früher auch so, ja, muss ich sagen, also ich war früher auch klühender Achter,
8 versus 8 Verfechter und hab mich über jeden der Outdeck geädert, hat aufgeregt
Aber mittlerweile hab ich die Doppelmoral hinter dem ganzen erkannt, weil man als Achtergruppe
ohne zu nachzudenken über Solo-Gruppen und Kleingruppen drüber rubbelt und sich danach
beschwert, dass die in einen, die Fights rein adden
Das hab ich früher nicht gecheckt, da hab ich mich immer übelst drüber aufgeregt,
dass man in Nice 8 versus 8 Kämpfen geadded wird
Heute ist mir das irgendwie klar, dass das eigentlich total bescheuert ist, ich kann nicht
erwarten, dass Kleingruppen nicht adden, wenn ich sie vorher den ganzen Tag umgerubbelt
hab
Hingegen, wenn ich als Achtergruppe auch mal ein paar Solos stehen lasse, ist die Chance
relativ hoch, dass diese Solos in meinen nächsten fairen Kampf nicht rein adden
Die haben ein gutes Setup, Ayla, BD, Skalde, andere erkenne ich nicht, er wackelt mir zu
viel rum
In Dark, dadurch, dass ich das auf den deutschen Software gespielt hab, haben sich so ein paar
Begriffe etabliert
Da ist Umrubbeln quasi gehört mit dabei
Ach guck mal, das ist der Joyce aus dem Stream hier
Da vorne kommt was, ein Solos Skalde
Gleich wirds wieder hell, ich glaub ab 4 Uhr wirds in Dark hell
Ich häng mich jetzt mal an die Dudes hier hinten dran
Da kriegen wir zumindest was weg
Ich mein, die finden das bestimmt nicht toll, wenn ich jetzt bei ihnen mit rein liege
Aber erstmal so zur Sicherheit damit laufen, bis wir da vorne durch sind
Ach, bist du das gar nicht gewesen, ok
Wo war's denn da vorne?
Die Alps, guckt euch das mal an
Was ist das denn?
Da fuck
Ist da der Ameisenhaufen oder?
Oh, ist der Brain Alp grade gespawnt
Der Brain Alp ist eingeloggt
Wir rennen jetzt einfach mal den Pet nach, dann finden wir wahrscheinlich seinen Besitzer
Der Brain Alp ist eingeloggt, ich sag's euch
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären
Also es da vorne waren gut und gern 6-7 Gruppen Alps grade
Echte Gruppen, echte Spieler, was man bei vielen MMOs heute betonen muss
Alle sechste Spieler
Und beste Klasse in Midgard ist selbstverständlich der Zwerg mit Augenklappe
Ach guck mal, da Xelson ist da am Start
Wir haben jetzt schon gleich Duo-Färbung
Was sollen wir denn hier machen gegen den Riesen-Alp-Zerg, ey
Vielleicht kommen wir hier oben lang
Aber es bringt uns ja auch nix
Was sind sie?
Schilder, was sind sie, Huge Zerg
Man owned nicht mehr, ist das so?
Was machen die hier, das ist noch nicht mal die aktive Zone
Piss dich, Alp
Geht nicht viel grade
Aber es ist halt Sonntag, Sonntagnachmittag ist das so
Wenn man jetzt in Gruppe spielt ist das natürlich mega nice
Entweder man zergt mit oder man kloppt so um
Vielleicht nicht den ganzen Zerg, aber zumindest ein paar
Solo ist das jetzt grade ziemlich blöd
Man kann nur versuchen ein bisschen rein zu enden und was abzuleaschen
Ich mein, guck mal wieviel das sind
Das sind 6 Gruppen oder so dahinten
Daran erkennt man die Pros, wenn sie springen
Ja, Toxic, was, Toxic, Masculinit, was, Masculinit, Toxic, Männlichkeit, ah verstehe
Auch wenn ich sie nicht aussprechen kann
Das wär so ein Guildennamen, den sie auf live sofort gebannt hätten
Oh, da kommt ne Gruppe
Ah, die taugen, die taugen, die kenn ich, die taugen
Die taugen aber auch nicht gegen 5 Millionen Alps
Warum, warum sind da so viele Alps schon wieder
Was soll ich denn machen jetzt
Viel zu viele, hier da kommt ein Tack
Ah, die sind auch nicht schlecht
Die, der Shami von denen streamt auch
Also wer achte Action sehen will
Bei denen streamt der Shami manchmal
Und die sind gut
Also ich hab schon ein paar Streams von denen angeguckt
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an die Gruppe, die wir früher auf Salisbury hatten
Hatte ein ähnliches Setup mit den BDs
Viel zu viele Alps
The fuck, was soll ich machen jetzt
Außer abhauen, was natürlich huge, spannendes Gameplay für ein Stream hier ist
Gerade vor Gegner wegrennen
Ah Leute, ist spannend, oder
Die big brain plays sind hier
Die fliegen hier so einer nach dem anderen
Die Tasse musst du nicht abgeben, Hanjal
Du musst nur die Phoenix Eier abgeben
Achtung Epilepsie Warnung
Ah, der Alps, dazu fällt mir nur das hier
Krasse Animation
Okay, vielleicht können wir jetzt wirklich absolute massive big brain plays machen
Und außen rumlaufen
Können wir die umlaufen
Nee die sind nicht blöd, die lassen sich nicht umlaufen
Lassen sich nicht umlaufen
Die Fortnite Tänze fehlen
Ich hab euch erzählt, dass ich letztens am Südbahnhof war und ein Typ auf die Straße
gesprungen ist vor dem Bus
Und den Loser Dance gemacht hat
Ein Nekro
Gut, der hat jetzt ganz schön gefeedet hier
Oder gespendet, wie man in Daox sagt
Feeden ist ja eher lol, in Daox spendet man
So Static, da laufen wir jetzt nicht rein
Das ist quasi ein riesengroßer HE-Stun, dieses Ding hier
So wie die Dudes das hier auch gerade merken
Der Bus losgefahren
Nee, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich sagen leider nicht
Aber dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass es eigentlich ziemlich bescheuert wäre zu sagen leider nicht
Weil ich mein, es müssen ja auch keine 8-jährigen wegen Fortnite Tänzen gerade vom Bus über
fahren werden, oder?
Aber ich fand's halt schon irgendwie affig wieder
Die Dalira, das ist auch so ein 24-7-Dude
Der ist immer on
Ich hab' Schiss, hier alleine zu laufen, äh, bei sechs Gruppen Alps
Läufst du in Gruppe oder nur solo?
Ich spiel hier eigentlich fast nur solo
Das Einzige, was ich manchmal mache, ist unsere Allianz hat abends immer 19.30 so eine Ali-RVR-Zergveranstaltung
Und das ist eigentlich ganz entspannend
Das ist dann natürlich hat, das ist dann kein hier GG-Nice-Fight, äh, sonst was
Sondern einfach, äh, Stick-Prain-Of-Car-Zergen, ja
Das ist abends ganz entspannend
Aber ansonsten spiel ich nur solo, oder ab und zu mal
Jetzt lagts wieder
Sind das?
Äh, ich spiel ab und zu mal ein bisschen Duo mit, mit, mit BDs oder mit nem zweiten Skalde
oder so
Hallo
Lasst mir was übrig, lasst mir was übrig
Nice
Kann nicht sein, ja
Dass ich nix abgeliegt kriege
Der Frazier, der Frazier will nicht, der Frazier will BDO spielen
Warum ist Ink?
Ink
Truff
Passion
Clary
Wo ist der Instamats da?
Macht man als Clary eigentlich nicht, weil es nur Immuntimer gibt, aber in der Situation
versteh ich's
Ah, schön drüber gerubbelt jetzt
Da unten ist, da unten ist ein Männer mit Speed
Wir müssen mal gucken, wie viele Alps das sind, vielleicht können wir da nämlich drauf
Da gehen wir drauf
Passion
So, jetzt machen wir Trick 17
Wir lassen die die Hexe anhauen
Dann macht die Hexe Quickcast, A-E-Mats
Und wenn die Hexe den Quickcast A-E-Mats raus hat, hau ich sie um
Lol
Get rekt
Huge Plays oder Big Brain
Genauso eingedreht, wie ich vorher gesagt hab
Das Dauauk-Orakel hat gesprochen
Ohhhh
Wer ist die Granny da?
Das ist ein Mob
Das ist ein Mob, die stehen ja manchmal rum, die kann man charmen und mitnehmen
200 IQ, ja
Ich würd schon fast sagen 900 eigentlich
Ach guck mal
Der Yoshimitsu ist da
Weg, weg, weg, weg
1000, ja
Warum sind das so viele?
Guck mal, da oben sind jetzt drei Hips
Vielleicht...
Ich probier mal abzuleaschen
What?
The fuck?
Ohhhh, jetzt hab ich alles rausgehauen für nichts, äh
Feels Bad Man
Feels Bad
Der eine Seite der Alp zerrt und auf der anderen Seite ne Gruppe Hips
Fuck
Da hab ich alles rausgehauen
Naja, stimmt ja gar nicht
Eigentlich hab ich nur eine Sache rausgehauen
Ja, Sonntagabend, Solo, R4R, so sieht's aus
Abzulöschen, niet nur hört sich falsch an
Ja, so nennt man's halt
Ich sehe, die Weep-Emotes werden wieder zur Anwendung gebracht
Grüß aus Aaren, moin, Common Sense
Aber wir haben immer noch einen 10k Schnitt, ich weiß nicht wo ich den her hab
Aber, ist okay
Für Sonntag, für Sonntagnachmittag, Sonntagabend, R4R, Solo
Alter, der Schleich hat sehr viel todes ey
Ich glaube Leute das war's, ich glaube es vorbei
Ich glaub Solo ist jetzt, ist jetzt, ist zu viel on
Ich mein, was ist das wieder?
30 Milliarden Alpschleicher
Was wollen wir da machen?
Hat sich was mit deinem Grill ergeben und bis jetzt...
Ne...
Also bis jetzt nicht.
Also nicht mehr als an Weihnachten auch.
Aber ich bin halt bei sowas immer...
Das ist bei mir immer so ne Sache.
Ich tu mir immer unglaublich schwer
mich für so zwischenmenschliche Sachen zu motivieren.
Versteht man was, wie ich das meine?
Weil man muss ja
egal in welchem Status sich das Ganze befindet.
Also es sei dann
davor, man ist scharf aufeinander und so,
da muss man Energie reinstecken.
Wenn es dann funktioniert, muss man da Energie reinstecken und irgendwie...
Zwischenmenschliche Sachen sind so anstrengend.
Ja, davor musst du dir Mühe geben und halt
dann halt auch übelst nachdenken und so, was machst du jetzt?
Äh, da und dann, ja, Dinger halt, ne?
EL-Dinger.
Das ist mir so anstrengend. Zwischenmenschliche Sachen sind mir einfach.
Da kann ich mich wenig für motivieren.
Leute, ich glaube, mit Solo ist vorbei heute.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Jetzt steht die Gruppe Hips vor unserem Keep.
Flix, Coden, das ist so extrem, würde ich bei mir nicht sagen, von der Ausprägung her.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, aber
ich hab da auch schon Anklänge, würde ich mal sagen, ja.
Ich hab auch keinen Bock auf Veranstaltungen mit vielen Leuten, vor allem, wenn ich viele Leute nicht kenne.
Und das liegt
hauptsächlich auch daran, weil es mir absolut egal ist, was die Leute erzählen.
Und auf so Veranstaltungen erzählen die Leute immer was. Manchmal, was sollste sonst so machen auf den Veranstaltungen?
Nice, die Alps haben Wachen gepullt.
Ja, direkt.
Oh ne, die Wachen laufen wieder zurück.
Wie soll das? Die Wachen sollen nicht zurücklaufen.
Haben die Wachen gezogen wieder?
Ne, die haben keine Wachen gezogen.
Ja, jetzt haben sie wieder Wachen gezogen.
Hallo, anklicken, please.
Und wieder weg, jawoll, er stirbt noch.
Das sind Hips, richtig, ja.
Ja, man darf nicht so viel drauf geben, was ich manchmal von mir gebe. Im Eifer des Gefechts
kann es da schon mal zu Verwechslungen kommen.
Der Bade, der Bade muss dran glauben, ja.
Guck mal, wo kommen denn die ganzen Midis auf einmal her?
Da sind jetzt ja auf einmal vier Gruppen mit.
Huge plays.
Massive.
Ja, das Doss in die Gegner rein, das war jetzt auch, auch
krasses Play.
Oh, easy clap.
Alter, tot.
So sieht das aus, wenn man mal einen ordentlichen Midi-Zerg am Start hat.
Da kann man auch mal was killen.
Zeuche.
Eine Minute 40.
Ja, das habe ich ja nicht ausprobiert.
Oh nein, ich habe noch solche, ich komme nicht weg.
Also solche halbiert die Heilung.
Selbstheilung hat man gar nicht mehr und man läuft 25% langsamer.
Das ist natürlich beim Abhauen ziemlich, ziemlich Mist.
Okay, ja, das Symbol ist, mit viel schwer, viel schneller an sich.
Und das, obwohl ich Sprinte und Speed an habe.
Und die solche läuft noch 40 Sekunden.
Alter, pox lauf, man beachte übrigens mal meinen Nachnamen, der mir noch nicht aufgefallen
ist.
Das ist für alle gerne Twitch-Emotes verwenden.
Am besten ist, hier läuft irgend so ein Typ rum, der heißt irgendwie 360, nee, Swag,
360, No Scope oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, denke ich mir auch, okay, der weiß
Bescheid.
Kann ich mal was ausprobieren, was ich schon immer ausprobieren wollte, beheilt der Heiler
solche?
Nee, natürlich nicht, aber blinkt auch so schon.
Ja, Puffin und Men, das ist mir aufgefallen, aber das ist im Internet halt so.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es auf Snapchat oder Tinder oder so ist, aber das ist im Internet
gefühlt.
Also auf allen Social-Media-Plattformen, sei es jetzt auf Twitter oder auf Instagram
oder so.
Die Mädels haben alle irgendwie entweder Bilder mit Filter drüber oder halt aus sehr,
sagen wir mal, günstigen Positionen, ja, also sprich, wenn, ich meine, ich verstehe
es ja irgendwie, würde ich auch so machen, dass man sich so ein bisschen von der Schokoladenseite
immer fotografiert, aber es gibt da welche, die haben Bilder, die haben mit der Realität
da wirklich gar nichts zu tun.
Da hast du Bilder teilweise, wo du denkst, wow, das ist aber echt sehr, sehr nice, ja,
und da gehst du mal auf Instagram und da ist dann ein Foto dabei, was halt nicht optimal
geschossen ist und denkst so, ist das echt die gleiche?
Ja, oder die Hand, genau, oder die Hand, das haben wir, das machen wir auch gerne.
Wie gesagt, dass man sich so von der Schokoladenseite fotografiert für so Apps, ist ja auf jeden
Fall verständlich, aber hat doch keiner was davon, wenn es mit der Realität nichts mehr
zu tun hat.
Jawoll, der Typ muss jetzt, was genau, ach, das ist der, sollte das eigentlich nicht mehr
funktionieren?
Sollten Nekros nicht ohne Pad nicht mehr casten können, oder wo ist das Nekro-Pad?
War da nicht was, haben sie sich eine der letzten Patches gefixt?
Die bürokratische, ich das ausdrücke, da muss man heutzutage aufpassen, weil sonst
hier.
What the fuck, Alter, wo kommen die denn jetzt her?
Ist, okay, Solo ist vorbei, Solo ist, Solo ist vorbei, dabei wenn wir schnell sind, können
wir die von hinten wegklatschen, vorne ist ne Gruppe drinne, da müssen sich aber die
ganzen Hips auch beeilen, die ganzen Midis auch beeilen.
Hallo, hallo, porten, please, weil die sind jetzt auf unserer Seite vom Wall, das heißt,
wenn wir schnell sind, aber die Alps sind nicht blöd hier, wahrscheinlich sind wir
halt schon durchgedrückt.
Der levelt hier an Klippenkäfer.
Ich zeig euch gleich noch ein bisschen was anderes vor dem Game, dann muss ich Pizza
futtern und vielleicht erwische ich ja das nächste Mal in der Zeit, wo man noch ordentlich
Solo spielen kann.
Ein toter Alps, Moment, sind da Hips noch mal, Moment, was ist hier los, was ist hier
gerade, Clarys unterbrechen ist das wichtigste, was man machen kann, also Clarys unterbrechen
ist wirklich das wichtigste, weil da haben die Alps keine Heilung mehr, meine Hexe unterbrechen
schadet auch nix, komm Clary, gib um, nice und jetzt mal wieder ein Stückchen raus hier,
weil ich zu viel Damage krieg, Level Up, die Lows hier, Level Up, ich bin im VR Gebiet,
oh der Dot, der Dot tickt ordentlich, ich muss mich erstmal heilen, ich muss mich heilen,
ich hab einen fetten Dot, zwei fette Dots drauf, Alter, huge Dot, das kam gerade richtig
da her, oh, weg klatschen, Kackmitte, wir tun jetzt einfach mal so, als sind wir besonders
Pro, weil wir ganz viele APM haben, weil Skalda auch so eine APM lastige Klasse ist, hier
so, 50.000 Quick Bindings ausführen, vielleicht soll ich mal meinen Heal Song anmachen, Freya
oder irgendeiner, passt mal auf mich auf, da ich jetzt nicht P-Art werde, gut, ich wurde
durch P-Art, ja, bisschen Unterschied, ich hab ja auch ein bisschen Guild Wars 2 gespielt,
der Unterschied ist, dass es ein komplett abgeschiedenes Gebiet ist in Guild Wars, er
korrigiert mich, wenn ich Mist erzähle, also der Unterschied zu Guild Wars gegen Dark,
dass es ein komplett abgeschloss, abgeschottetes Gebiet ist, dieses World vs. World und in
Dark ist es halt Teil der Spielwelt und du hast halt auch Einflüsse drauf, vielleicht
soll ich mal den Turk interupten, bleibst du stehen, Azzelmaul ab 50 Aber, bleib stehen,
stehen bleiben, Alter, kam der Typ von hinten und slampt mich, Schild in die Fresse gedrückt,
ja, und in Dark ist es halt Teil der Spielwelt, du kannst, ich zeig euch das gleich nochmal,
bevor ich Schluss mache, ich lauf mal quasi vom Grenzgebiet bei uns direkt in die, wo
kann man am besten mit Level 10 hin, SE, Agir, Agir am Strand ist bis Level 20, glaub ich
ganz gut, Kopf aber auch nicht mal ganz sicher oder Mehrquot, Mehrquot ist mit 20 dann ganz
gut, oh schon wieder so viele Alps und es hat auch Auswirkungen drauf, weil du hast
zum Beispiel, jedes Reich hat zwei Relikte, passt das von der Menge her, die Alps gegen
die, die Midis gegen die Alps, jedes Reich hat zwei Relikte und wenn das andere Reich
die Relikte erobert, kriegen sie halt die Vorteile davon, das sind 10% mehr Damage,
10% mehr, 10% mehr Nahkampfschaden, 10% mehr Magieschaden und du kannst es halt bis,
du kannst halt auch beide Relikte haben, also sprich, du kannst als, warum bin ich schon
wieder gestunt, wenn laufend gestunt, ey, den erwischen wir noch, wo war ich gerade dabei,
was wollte ich gerade sagen, genau, du kannst also beispielsweise hier als Mid, kannst du
das Alp und das Hip, sagen wir mal, stärker gelegt haben, das sind 20% mehr Nahkampfschaden,
weil ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin, wie sie das in Phönix gemacht haben, also es hat
direkt und das ist Nahkampfschaden, der PvP und PvM zählt, also es gibt hier keine Begrenzung,
das ist in der Ausrüstung auch so, alle Stats, die ich auf der Rüstung habe, zählen im
PvM und im PvE, meine Reichsfähigkeiten, die ich hab hier, zählen im RVR und im PvM,
also es zählt alles, überall, es gibt keine extra PvP-Ausrüstung, keine extra PvM-Ausrüstung,
das einzige, was wir auf dem Server hier haben, ist das Amulett, aber das ist nur eine Custom-Sache
von Phönix, die bringt ein bisschen Bonus in PvM, guck mal da, der will gekillt werden,
die Laps, ah schön abgeleashed, habe ich den Deathblow gekriegt, nein, I send it, Speed,
Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed,
Augenschmaus, jetzt sieht sie zum Kotzen aus, nein, ich renne da nicht alleine rein, erstmal
warten bis die anderen Mits am Start sind, so kann man ordentlich reinleashen, bleibst
so stehen, auch stehenbleiben, Hallo, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed,
Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed, Speed,
alleine nicht durch
Und das ist leider ein nachteil von von den alten grenzgebieten hier dass die leute durch diesen wall durch müssen das macht das das nimmt viel
viel schwung so auch ein bisschen raus
Übrigens dass ich jetzt durch den gegen die wand rennen ist absicht weil in dark ist es so
Das ist auch so eine mechanik die dir keine erklärt
Wenn du stehst und läufst los hast du eine beschleunigung beschleunigungszeit wenn du wo dagegen läufst und dann wegläufst hast du die nicht
Obwohl du sie auch nicht hast ist wenn du gegner stickst da bist du instant bist du instant auf full speed
Das heißt wenn man die gegner abfacken will macht man sowas gegen den gegner
Oder am besten auch mit rumspringen dabei
Ok wir gehen jetzt mal auf den wall um gucken was da so abgeht wieviel gegner da sind
Es hält sich in grenzen guck mal das ist eine eineinhalb gruppen oder so
Wenn die middys durchpushen würden werden die gegner kaputt
Aber die middys hauen lieber ab
Das ist natürlich ziemlich blöd. Was sagst du so einen neuen star wars game hab ich mir noch nichts nichts von angeschaut
Jetzt werden es immer mehr alps ich glaube da gehen wir nicht durch
Ich weiß auch nicht wo ich sonst hin soll
Von da hinten kommen hippie gruppen und alps stehen hinterm wall also eigentlich bleibt mir das grad nichts anderes übrig außer vielleicht das ein oder andere
Den ein oder anderen abzuleaschen der hier durchkommt
Das hat keinen sinn
Ich hau ab
Das hat keinen sinn ich laufe mit den stückchen weg und dann schaue ich mal ob ich solo irgendwas finde
Wat
Und wir von wo kamen die tuns denn jetzt schon wieder
Muss erst mal weg ich muss mir erstmal heilen ansonsten kein kein taug
Und ich muss meinen halt rein nehmen
Ein
Gute gespielt mit dies oh meine buffs gehen weg muss abhauen
Da oben ist ein scout
Das können wir da drauf
Vielleicht können wir darauf
Da können wir nicht drauf weil die ganzen alps schon aus durch die wald durch sind dann verpissen wir uns jetzt
Wir machen jetzt Piss dich, Alde. Aber ganz weit weg hier.
So, ähm, genau, also wo war ich grad? Der Unterschied zwischen Dark Guild Wars 2, FVR System, ja ich hab's, wie gesagt, ich hab ja auch nicht viel.
Guck mal, das ist doch mal ganz, das sieht nach einer passablen Gruppe Midis aus.
Vielleicht könnten die ein paar Alps killen.
Nee, glaub ich nicht.
Glaub ich nicht, die laufen, die laufen so in Richtung Nice Fight.
Hier stehen wir nicht weiter auf dem Keks.
Noch da?
Ja.
Gut tut.
Und was ich halt wirklich schon darauf finde, dass es eigentlich für jeden was bieten kann.
Man muss aber halt sagen, ich mein, es hat PvM, das hat auch, das hat viel, sehr viel Gruppen-PvM, also Solo-PvM ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Aber es ist halt nicht zu vergleichen mit irgendwie 150 vorgefertigten, durchgeskripten Instanzen, wie das WoW hat.
Das gibt's hier nicht.
Es gibt, es gibt hier, äh, Xsonics, danke für den, danke für den Host.
Ähm, es gibt hier auf dem Software, aber das ist eine Phoenix-Eigenheit, eine, eine High-End-PvM-Instanz.
Und die ist auch relativ schwer.
Und halt jede Menge Farm, Farm-Dungeons.
Und bis auf eine Instanz ist auch hier alles Open-World.
Also sprich, es gibt keine Instanzen.
Was auch heißt, dass der Epic-Dungeon, also da, wo man, wo man seine, seine, sein Gier quasi zusammen mal kriegt,
den kannst du nur zweimal am Tag machen, weil die Dinger eine Stunde, einen Respawn von, glaub ich, zwölf Stunden haben.
Da merkt man halt, es kommt noch aus der Zeit Pre-WoW, Pre-Instanzen.
Hier ist auch nichts.
Hier ist so das Super-Secret-Level-Spot von Hips.
Da stellen sie sich immer hin und denken, es finden sie keiner.
Tja, was machen wir jetzt?
Gehen wir jetzt in Main und lassen uns umzergen.
Und dann gehen wir mal auf gut Glück ein bisschen weiter ins Gebiet hinten und gucken, ob wir da was finden.
Aber da, da dürfte nicht so viel sein.
Meinung zu dem ganzen Epic-Exklusiv-Drama.
Boah, da muss ich jetzt ausholen.
Okay, wo fange ich am besten an?
Ich finde es affig, dass Spiele wie Metro von Snowdonia am Seekamp, ja, Alptask ist vorbei.
Und vorher war, war Hipzirk in, in HW, da bin ich nicht durchgekommen und porten konnten wir noch nicht.
Alptask ist jetzt vorbei.
Ich könnte höchstens noch mal mitgucken, mit irgendwie zwischen Alpwall und Hipwall im Gebüsch rumlaufen oder so.
Also Epic Store.
Genau, also ich finde es affig, dass Spiele wie Metro entfernt werden.
Metro war ja erst auf Steam und wurde ja quasi gelöscht.
Dass es jetzt werden das Exklusive über Epic Store vertreiben.
Aber da finde ich affig sowas in der Richtung.
Auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen, ich finde gut, dass es den Epic Store gibt.
Denn, und ich glaube, das ist eine Sache, die kann man zwar diskutieren, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es da so viele Argumente dafür gibt.
Oder eher gegen, weil das Steam Konkurrenz braucht ist, glaube ich, kann man nicht viel gegen sagen, oder?
Denn mein Steam hat faktisch keine Konkurrenz.
Du hast GOG, ja, aber das ist für die meisten AAA-Titel ja, kommt es nicht in Frage.
Du hast so Dinger wie Origin und Uplay.
Ich meine, ernsthaft, Leute, Uplay.
Wer fällt mir jetzt zu Uplay wirklich nicht ein?
Origin hast du, das ist halt nur EA, internes Zeug.
Also wirklich eine Konkurrenz zu, so wirklich eine Konkurrenz zu Steam gibt es ja nicht.
Das heißt, aus dem Gesichtspunkt finde ich es gut, dass es eine Konkurrenz zu Steam gibt.
Und ich finde es auch gut, dass die bei Epic wohl mehr an die Entwickler ausschütten.
Also Konkurrenz tut Steam mit Sicherheit gut.
Die Praktiken mit diesem Exklusivkram kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten, aber auf der anderen Seite,
man muss es ja immer, so unabhängig, wie sehr es einem auf den Sack geht,
dass man jetzt zwei Sachen parallel haben muss.
Aber man muss sich es auch mal aus Sicht von Epic überlegen,
wie willst du denn die Leute breitflächig, außer mit Fortnite, dazu bekommen,
deine Plattform auszuprobieren oder auf deine Plattform zu kriegen,
wenn du keine exklusiven Inhalte hast, die die Leute wollen?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Du musst die Leute irgendwie auf deine Plattform kriegen oder auf deine Plattform locken.
Ich bin da wirklich, ich bin da recht spiegelspalten.
Ich meine, auf der einen Seite hätte ich gerne ein Client, der alles hat.
Auf der anderen Seite hätte ich auch gerne Konkurrenz zu Steam.
Origin ist der Sack schlechthin.
Also Origin ist wirklich der Bodensatz von dem ganzen Zeug.
Ich habe ja mal ein Video zu Origin gemacht,
wo ich ein bisschen Debugged habe, was das ist.
Ich meine, im Prinzip ist Battle.net und Steam und so auch nichts,
nicht viel anderes als einen Browser in einem eigenen Fenster.
Aber ich hatte ja auf YouTube mal ein Video gemacht,
wo wir uns Origin ein bisschen genauer angeguckt haben,
wo wir sogar in den Debugged-Modus von Origin angeschaltet haben und geguckt haben.
Das war halt nur so ein glorifying Browser als Origin quasi.
So, hier ist jetzt natürlich nichts.
Wir gehen jetzt nochmal in mein Grenzgebiet von meinem Reich
und schauen mal, was da so abgeht.
Wir weipen uns jetzt hier an der Grenzfestung.
Vielleicht kriegen wir noch die ein oder anderen gelben Bargläfeln hin.
Schauen wir mal.
Dann gehen wir nochmal mit gerade gucken, was da so los ist.
Also, ich habe immer noch 11k die Stunde.
Wo haben wir denn die APs her?
Morgens ist es eher so wie 20k.
Da flutscht es aber auch viel mehr.
Gruppe grauer, grauer.
Ja, übrigens, jedes Reich hat zwei Grenzfestungen.
Die Hibis haben ja einmal liegen und ganz unten am Arsch der Welt haben die noch kein,
aber da ist keiner.
Oder wenige, so ganz wenige sind da eigentlich.
Ein paar Solo-Leveler vielleicht.
Bist vor allem bis weggelaufen.
Stand noch auf dem Hügel.
Was? Wo? Wo? Da.
Das glaube ich jetzt nicht.
Warum hat mein Mats nicht funktioniert?
Schleicherzerker.
Warum hat mein Mats gerade nicht funktioniert?
Mein mittlerer Maustaste hat nicht reagiert.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist die Katze unten links, ja.
Aber das Bild von der Katze.
Die Alps kriegen meine APs nicht.
Hallo. Ach guck mal da.
Ein Solo-Silvan. Den können wir jetzt noch killen.
Hat zwar nicht viel Leben, aber für den sollte es noch reichen.
Das ging nicht viel.
So, vipern wir uns mal.
Nee, nee, nee.
Vielleicht, wir heilen uns noch, dass die Alps keine APs kriegen.
Vielleicht werden wir auf P-Art von einem Hipschleicher.
Schauen wir mal.
Da brauche ich Leben für die.
Da brauche ich Leben.
Und ich brauche vor allem Seuche.
Wer auf 40 Sekunden Seuche, ey.
Wer hat sich das dann ausgedacht, dass das eine gute Idee ist?
Wie findest du denn das Lied Deutschland von Rammstein, das du nicht gehört?
Ist das das, wo es sich alle so drüber aufgeregt haben,
dass sie irgendwie in Häftlingsuniform rumgelaufen sind oder so?
Das habe ich nur auf Twitter so am Rande mitgekriegt,
wo ich mir gedacht habe, ey, alles richtig gemacht, Rammstein.
Ihr seid im Gespräch.
Und ich mein, als wäre es das erste Mal, dass irgendwie Rammstein
so ein bisschen fragwürdige Sachen zeigt in einem Video.
Nicht das erste Mal, ne?
Das ist mit Seuche jetzt ziemlich mystisch hier.
Einmal schnell einen Heal rausgehauen.
Alter, was die für eine Range haben, die Pilze.
Ah.
So.
Okay, ich recke mal eine Runde.
Nee, Joyce, das sind drei Alps.
Das ist schwierig. Drei Alps, und die sind auch nicht so low.
Da machen wir nichts.
Zwei Infi so im Sinne.
Zumal ich die zwei wichtigsten, ja, das kann ich immer haben.
Da können wir nichts machen.
Ich stürze mich jetzt in die Grenzfestung.
Und dann gucken wir uns doch mal kurz mit Guard-RVR-Gebiet an.
Davor ziehe ich noch mal ein Buff dran, falls noch Ink ist.
Auf zehn Sekunden.
Auf zehn Sekunde.
Eine Sekunde.
In Dark dauern Sekunden gefühlt.
Zehnmal so lang.
So.
Schauen wir mal.
Ob es da noch was gibt, was wir killen können.
Ansonsten gucken wir uns noch mal eine Runde mit Guard an.
Und ich zeige euch vorher noch mal, wie das halt in dem Game gemacht ist,
dass man einen fließenden Übergang hat zwischen den Gebieten.
Und übrigens, falls irgendwie einer zufällig jetzt von Phoenix zugucken sollte.
Es ist sehr gut, dass ihr das Stream-Delay rausgemacht habt.
Weil ohne Stream-Delay könnte ich nicht spielen.
Es war meiner Meinung nach von Anfang an keine so gute Idee mit dem Stream-Delay.
Aber besser später als gar nicht.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine super Entscheidung, das rauszunehmen.
Weil die Regel war vorher, man muss zehn Minuten Stream-Delay reinmachen.
Wobei, man kann nicht Twitch-Livestream mit zehn Minuten Delay.
Also zumindest nicht, wenn man mit Leuten interagieren will.
Sonst geht es nicht.
Wie willst du mit zehn Minuten Delay mit deinem Chat interagieren?
Geht nicht.
Wie lange bin ich eigentlich schon?
Was ist denn da?
11?
Hallo?
Hallo 11.
Jaja, stun mich ruhig.
Lol.
Passt mir auf.
Jaja.
Ist gut.
Erstmal heilen.
Hallo, ich hab das angeklickt.
Oh, ich renne ja gar nicht.
Oh, das ist jetzt ziemlich, ziemlich räudig.
Kann er mal sterben?
Fuck, ich muss weg.
Uuuh.
Go, go, go.
Pass auf, jetzt kommen gleich die Alps.
Jaja, ist gut.
Wow, der Wom ist ja so schnell da, Dude.
Ja, Midis rettet mich.
Midis rettet mich.
Perfekt.
Wo kommen die denn jetzt her?
Wo kommen...
What the fuck?
Warum ist ne Gruppe Midis vorliegen?
Was machen die hier?
Ich mein, ich würde mich jetzt nicht beschweren.
Die haben mich im Endeffekt, haben die mir grad den Arsch gerettet, ja.
Aber was machen die hier?
Äh, Levelgruppe, machen wir nix.
Ja, Pavilion Man, das ist ein sehr guter Punkt.
Och Gott, die Alps.
Scheiß Ficker, ey.
Ich stürz mich jetzt in die Grenzfestung.
So, du wirst jetzt noch gemetzt.
Dass du da schön ewig rumstehst und hoffentlich P-Art wirst von irgendwelchen Hips.
Hör auf.
Himmys, traut euch.
Oh.
Oh, es werden immer mehr.
Jawoll, mach sie fertig.
Hip.
Hopp.
Das wird nix.
Der reckt.
Der pilst erst mal auf.
Jawoll, die Midis kommen.
Sehr schön.
Okay, wir gehen erst mal nach Midgard gucken, was da so los ist.
Ja, also der Pavilion Man hat einen guten Punkt gebracht.
Ähm, wenn sich Streaming-Dienste beziehungsweise die, äh, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Streaming-Dienste beziehungsweise die, äh, Games, wie heißt es?
Games as a Service und Plattformen und äh, alle Spiele nur noch über irgendwelche, ähm, Trittanbieterportale und so, wenn sich das durchgesetzt hat.
Dann kann es durchaus sein, dass man sowas hier nicht mehr machen kann, ja.
Also sprich, dass das privaten Servern in Riegel vorschiebbar spielen und dass generell Spiele noch gespielt werden, wenn die offiziellen Server abgeschaltet werden.
Geschweige denn, weil du das Spiel vielleicht gar nicht mehr bekommst, wenn der Hersteller sagt, ah ja, Support eingestellt, gibts nicht mehr zum Download.
Also du bist wirklich auf, auf, ja, wie heißt es so?
Verdärmen und Gedeih darauf angewiesen, dass sie das halt weiter zur Verfügung stellen.
Okay, wir können das gleich mal porten.
Ja, das, das stimmt schon. Ich mein, man muss sich schon überlegen und man hat, man sieht den Trend.
Ähm, überlegt euch mal, wie viele Spiele der letzten Konsolengeneration, also 360 und PS3, hattet ihr als echtes Spiel in der Hand?
Wahrscheinlich 90%.
Wie viele Spiele der aktuellen Konsolengeneration auf dem PC habt ihr in der Hand?
Das ist wahrscheinlich 10%, wenns hochkommt.
Also die haben es schon ganz gut hingekriegt, dass man, äh, also die haben es schon ganz gut geschafft, dass Spiele nicht mehr weiter verkauft werden können, zum Beispiel.
Auf der 360 und der PS3 konntest du ohne Probleme, wenn du die Spiele gebraucht, einfach kaufen auf Ebay.
Oder damals auch auf dem PC.
Solange das Steam-Pflicht ist, war das da auch schon lange vorbei.
Äh, Jumpern Center.
Warum ist es eigentlich schon wieder dunkel?
Ihr fühlt euch heute in Dark den ganzen Tag dunkel.
Man sieht auch schon, Midgard Grenze ist auch wieder komplett anders.
Ziemlich viel Schnee.
Seen, es gibt auch einen Bergsee, ich finde das ist eigentlich die hübscheste Karte im Spiel mit dem Bergsee in Midgard.
Problem ist nur, die Saison am Arsch der Welt, da geht überhaupt keiner hin.
Wo lauf ich eigentlich gerade lang?
Da muss ich lang.
Äh, und ich glaube auch nicht, weil es da gerade im Chat rum geht, ich glaube auch nicht, dass Cloud Gaming das ablösen wird, komplett.
Also ich glaube, es wird für viele Leute eine Alternative sein.
Also quasi für irgendwelche, nennen wir es mal, casual Leute, dass man Spiele über Cloud spielt.
Die die halt beispielsweise gar keinen ordentlichen Gaming-PC haben.
Aber es wird eine Alternative sein.
Also jemand, der was weiß ich, jedes Jahr einfach mal das neue Assassin's Creed spielen will und dafür kein PC haben, keine Konsole haben.
Für den wird Cloud Gaming schon so das Mittel der Wahl sein in Zukunft.
Das sind aber auch alle Spiele, die es nicht großartig interessiert, ob du Delay hast.
Alles, was irgendwie competitive gespielt wird, wird niemals über die Cloud gespielt. So einfach ist es.
Casual Spiele, nicht nur mobile Games.
Oh, Albion hat hier gerade gecaptured und ich seh nix.
Das ist schon mal schlecht, das heißt, es ist irgendwie ein Schleicher-Zerg.
Okay, geh mal weg hier.
Mit Casuals... ne Casuals sind im Prinzip, im Prinzip sag ich mal, sind Casuals, die Spieler halt nicht competitive spielen.
Als in dem jeweiligen Spiel, ja.
Ansonsten gibt es da noch zig Abstufungen, die man machen kann.
Du hast so die, du hast so die peace of mind, wenn man die
€$$
$$$
$$
Abstufungen die man machen kann. Du hast so die, so, du hast so die, die, die mobile
Pay-to-win-Casual-Leute, also das die eigentlichen Casuals oder die Leute die allen hypes nachrennen
Ist hier noch was?
Ohoho, minne, alter, get rekt, get rekt, das war keine so gute Idee mich anzugreifen
Leute die zum Beispiel nicht casual spielen sind Leute für mich die halt
Versuchen sich zu verbessern in einem game, die nicht einfach nur einloggen und sagen oh nice, have fun
und
dann halt auch mit nach drei monaten noch irgendwie
Scheiße, die es nicht geschafft haben irgendwie eine level up und mal eine ordentliche klasse zu spielen, mal ordentliche ausrüstung zu haben, mal irgendwie
ordentlich was treffen zu können, mal ordentlich die map zu kennen, das sind halt für mich so die jüngsten casual-leute, gibt's viele
Es ist auch nix verwerfliches dran, ich krieg bloß immer anfälle, wenn ich mir das teilweise angucke
auch hier in downq wenn der leute das die das spiel seit 20 jahr spielen und irgendwie nicht wissen
wo es zum ball geht oder so
fuck was ist hier los
Ja aber alles was in irgendeiner form competitive gespielt wird oder halt auch nur in spiele wo leute sich versuchen nur zu verbessern was halt das
Potenzial dafür hat also in spiel dass das irgendwie competitive tauglich ist, es muss nicht unbedingt e-sport tauglich sein, battlefield ist nicht wirklich e-sport
tauglich, aber es ist ein gewisser wettkampf drinnen ja, das sind spiele die werden leute die das spiel ernsthaft spielen nie über cloudservice
nie über cloudservice, das kannst du vergessen
das wirst du nie über cloudservice spielen, zumindest nicht die leute die sich darin verbessern wollen
weil die können ja alle nicht zaubern die ganzen cloudservices
Es kann jetzt auch kein cloudservice sagen, ich habe jetzt nur 5 millisekunden delay, das geht nicht, lichtgeschwindigkeit
Ja direkt bei physics, das funktioniert halt einfach nicht
Und überlegt euch mal was für ein akk die leute schon machen mit einem 60 herz monitor zu einem 144 herz und 240 herz monitor
zu einem 144 herz und 240 herz monitor, das ist ein bruchteil von dem was du an delay bekommst über einen cloud streaming dienst
Was ist mit 5g
War das mits, war das hips, was war das da oben, ich hab's net gesehen
Ach das sind, das sind minis gewesen, das erschreckt mich doch nicht so
5g, also das daran, das ist gar nicht das problem, die bandbreite ist nicht das problem für cloud dienste
also ja in deutschland an vielen stellen schon allerdings an sich ist die bandbreite nicht das problem bei cloud diensten
sondern die verzögerung und mehr bandbreite bringt nicht automatisch weniger latenz
Äh midis, midis warum geht ihr denn da nicht ruf, weißte ich dachte, ich dachte mir schon so ich helf euch mal
Ich muss weg
Okay wenn die sos zünden, zünd ich auch mal sos und renne in die andere richtung weg
Und ich hab wieder seuche, so ne 5, 3 minuten 34 seuche, hallo was ist das
Wer von den designers dachte sich 3 minuten 34 seuche, was ist das
Was ist das, wer von den designers dachte sich 3 minuten 25 seuche, das ist eine gute gameplay entscheidung
What, what
Moment, was ist hier los
Okay ich bin stun immun, ich bin stun immun, das ist schonmal sehr nice für mich
Ich hoffe der versucht mich zu stunnen, stun mich alter, stun mich, mats läuft gleich aus
Sag mal, was ist denn mit mein, habt ihr gesehen ob ich geneasetet, ach ich war geneasetet
Ich sehs grad in meiner vorschau, ich wundere mich schon warum geht mein mats nicht raus, was ist da los
Ist das ne mmo, jo
Klingt nach spätmittel alter 3 minuten seuche, die wären froh gewesen im mittelalte hätten die nur 3 minuten seuche gehabt
Okay ich glaube leute die solo zeit ist vorbei, solo zeit ist vorbei, also ich zeig euch jetzt mal was
Das hier ist quasi so das mainland, also das hier inklusive allen diesen karten hier ist quasi mitgab das, ja was heißt mainland
Wie würde man das auf deutsch sagen, das nicht grenzgebiet, das normale gebiet von diesem realm halt
Und jedes reich hat 2 grenzfestungen, wenn man da durchgeht kommt man ins grenzgebiet
Sprich das ist quasi ohne ladebildschirm, flüssig durchlaufen
Vom mainland ins grenzgebiet rein und das ist das was irgendwie dauernd auch von der dynamik her ausmacht
Das poggers land
Wie jetzt kein ladescreen, kein ladescreen, siehs doch gar nicht, lauf doch durch
Das einzige wo du laden musst ist, wenn du in andere reiche wechselst, also wenn du in albion porte oder nach hip porte
Dann lade ich das einmal und man könnte theoretisch, aber ich sag nur mal ganz theoretisch, weil dann wirst du wahrscheinlich gebannt wenn du das hinkriegst
Nachdem hier kein ladebildschirm ist zwischen dem quasi privaten, ne zwischen dem nicht zugänglichen mainland und dem grenzgebiet
Könnten es theoretisch Gegner schaffen durch die grenzfestung durch zu kommen
Ganz theoretisch allerdings nur, weil die wachen sind übelstark und wahrscheinlich wirst du sofort gebannt
Wenn du irgendwie den clinch findest, das ist auf jeden fall nicht gedacht
Aber es wäre theoretisch möglich, zeige euch übrigens mal mein house in game
Das spiel hat auch ein super housing system, es wäre theoretisch möglich
Auf live ist das einmal passiert in 20 jahren, dass es spieler geschafft haben durch die grenzfestung durchzukommen in das hinterland
Also quasi sozusagen in die level gebiete und so, also das ist auch nicht gewollt von dem spiel
Aber man sieht halt, dass es eben so aufgewollt ist, dass es theoretisch möglich wäre
Das spiel hat ein super housing system, vielleicht porte ich mal hier zu meinem house, das sieht ziemlich billig aus
Also hier gibt es jetzt quasi sechs, sieben verschiedene housing gebiete und da kann man sich halt häuschen drin kaufen
Von billig hütte, wie ich hier habe und die anderen hier haben, bis zu villa
Und hat halt vorteile, denn man kann hier seine drops verkaufen, also sprich ich habe hier den händler, der übrigens wieder 339 gold drin hat
Ich habe einen händler, da kann ich drops reinlegen und die werden dann im marketplace angeboten, da kann ich danach suchen
Und von innen sieht mein haushalt nach nichts aus, ich habe da auch nichts eingerichtet drin
Das schöne ist, man hat hier quasi seine walls, seinen account walls, seinen persönlichen walls und man hat einen teleporter, wo man überall hin kann
Ich kann jetzt mal zum beispiel zu unserem gildenhaus porten, das sieht ein bisschen pompöser aus, ist das da, schon ein bisschen fetter
Und da ist jetzt ein bisschen mehr zu sehen
Da haben sie auch drinnen ein bisschen Trophäen aufgestellt, ein bisschen zeugs auf den boden gelegt
Und es hat auch verschiedene stockwerke, also hier unten vom teleporter bis zum vault, bis zur schatzkiste
Dann zum binstone, wo man respawnen kann dran
Und das housing system ist cool, das habe ich so auch noch in keinem anderen spiel gesehen, geht quasi bis unter das dach geschoss
Man kann crafting sachen, man kann zum beispiel algenitig rein machen, wo man craftet
Das crafting system von dark ist eh auch was, was ich, ich sage es ganz oft, aber vieles in dark hat, hat nur dark, hat irgendwie kein anderes spiel
Das crafting system ist jetzt nicht super anspruchsvoll, im prinzip kaufst du materialien und craftest vor dich hin, um skillpunkte zu kriegen
Aber wie es eingebunden ist in dem spiel ist halt sehr nice
Willst du hurriker auch, das haben wir glaube ich, haben wir glaube ich
Es ist nämlich ziemlich cool, weil diese ganzen buffs, die ich hier habe, das sind tränke, das hier zum beispiel
Und das ist playercrafted, das sind keine drops, die gibt es nicht
Das gibt es nicht als drops, das ist alles playercrafted, also sprich es hat sinn, wenn man alchemy craft, wenn man alchemy skillt, wenn man alchemy crafter macht
Weil du brauchst die tränke und du kannst die tränke auch verkaufen
Also wenn ich jetzt hier zum beispiel suche short of, da krieg ich hier ganz viele tränke im angebot in der housingzone 52 seiten tränken
Und das ist alles playercrafted
Und die rüstung hier, na das sind drops, die rüstung hier zum beispiel ist playercrafted
In daok hast du eine mischung an aus drops, quest rüstung und zum größten teil playercrafted
Ja daok wird noch entwickelt, allerdings live ist mehr oder weniger tot
Phoenix wird sehr aktiv entwickelt von einem team aus freiwilligen leuten
Also das hier ist ja phoenix, wohlgemerkt nicht live
Und die haben viele coole sachen gemacht
Also das crafting in dem spiel, eine der wenigen mmo's finde ich, wo crafting richtig sinn macht, wenn man das lernt
Also ich persönlich mag crafting in daok nicht, ich hab keinen crafter, aber allein schon dadurch, dass ich playercrafted rüstung an hab, sieht man, dass das was bringt
Du musst die rüstung craften und dann kannst du noch weiter, kannst du noch spellcrafting, kannst du craften, dann kannst du quasi auch stats auf die rüstung machen
Also das ist wirklich durchdacht
Ist allerdings, jetzt porte ich mal in die hauptstadt, ist allerdings auch so ein bisschen wissenschaft für sich, wie man das kombiniert
Hast du eine lizenz?
Klar, natürlich, für alles
Alles lizenziert, jetzt bin ich arm
Tony Südmann auf unter der brücke, aber ich kann streamen und kann alle musik laufen lassen
Anzeige ist raus
Das ist übrigens hier die mitgard hauptstadt, da hast du alle wichtigen händler, die man so brauchen im spiel
Inklusive dem teleporter, den vault, den reskin npc, hier ist übrigens der porter zur highend pvm instanz, die einzige instanz, die es überhaupt gibt
Skin, skin möglichkeiten, ja, effekte auf die waffen machen, weil das auge ist ja mit hier
Links gibt es auch einen grafik bug
Sind die überhaupt noch?
Ja hier, grafik bug
Und wer auf vo steht, kann sich auch
Kann sich auch auf die rüstung
Ich glaube es ist gerade verbackt
Kann sich auch auf die rüstung so riesen schulter platten machen lassen, weil da stehen ja die volleute irgendwie drauf
Genau
Also jedes reich hat auch eine hauptstadt
In albion ist das kamelot, wer hätte das gedacht, wie gesagt das ganze ist ja so ein bisschen
König artus mäßig angelehnt
Und mitgard hat jordheim, das ist eigentlich so eine handsammlung aus hütten
Die nicht sonderlich tolle aussieht
Genau, soll ich gucken, ob ich euch zum schluss den rvr dungeon zeigen kann
Geht leider nicht
Es gibt nämlich ein dungeon, da kommen die leute rein, da kann das reich rein, was die meisten festungen im grenzgebiet hat
Man sieht schon, dass es alles so ein bisschen hängt es miteinander zusammen
Also pvp ist hier zwar theoretisch optional
Aber pvm resultate haben auswirkungen auf das komplette reich
Was halt ziemlich cool ist
Und einen wirklich guten charakter kriegt man eigentlich nur hin, wenn man pvm macht, weil man braucht reichfähigkeiten
Realm abilities, sonst ist Müll
So, ich muss jetzt langsam mal was essen, wie lange bin ich denn schon on
Weißt, hat jemand irgendwie better twitch tv oder so installiert
Oder kann mal einer bitte als ausrufzeichen abtime machen
Nice, 3 stunden, ok
Dann werde ich jetzt was futtern gehen
Falls ihr noch fragen zu dem spiel habt, könnt ihr ja noch stellen, ich bin noch 2-3 min
Porte jetzt mal ins housing und kaufe noch ein paar tränke
Aber am schluss, wie hat es euch denn gefallen
Leider war solomäßig nicht mehr allzu viel zu holen
Weil zu viel Gezerge war
Kann man leider nichts machen
Genau und falls ihr Interesse habt das zu spielen
Wie gesagt macht ihr ausrufzeichen server
Ihr könnt ja gucken, wie der private server heißt, wie gesagt kostet nichts, das ist ein privater server
Dementsprechend auch ohne irgendwie garantien oder so
Und wenn ihr einen neuen char erstellen wollt ist das relativ simpel
Ihr sucht euch einen reich aus, kann ich jetzt nicht machen, weil ich hier schon eingeloggt war
Sucht euch einen reich aus, macht euch einen neuen charakter
Also sowas zum beispiel wie hier level 1 spawndancer erstellen
Und dann startet ihr in einem der startgebiete
Kilt ein paar mobs und am besten sucht ihr euch eine gruppe und levelt mit denen zusammen
Weil dark ist, auch wenn man auf phoenix relativ einfach solo leveln kann
Ist dark eigentlich ein spiel, boah was mit meinem ui los hier
Was ist für ein live balken
Ja
Hier mein ui ist ein bisschen verrutscht, das muss man ja mal ein bisschen verschieben
Es ist ein spiel, was auf jeden fall in der gruppe viel viel besser ist als solo
Man startet ihr, geht hier raus, killt ein paar mobs und levelt
Und guckt euch das an
Das schöne ist, dass man in dark seinen charakter halbwegs kann, wenn man 50 ist
Übrigens poggers ist mein heiler, da hatte ich den besten namen wieder
Aber solo kannst du halt keinen heiler spielen
Solo spielst du eigentlich nur hier
Den namen
Gut
Ppk
Ich glaube einen rename respect gibt es nicht
Aber ppk wäre ein super name für einen skalde gewesen
Jetzt heiße ich halt nur omega low mit nachname
Ok leute
Gehe ich jetzt was futtern
Und wir sehen uns bis dann, machts gut
Cu